don't have any documents in front of me
and I didn't receive anything via email
so I don't
know um representative major this is
Chris yes the process of putting an
email together to send to representive
Aaron representative Smith and
representative Lang to make sure they
have all the
documents okay so you'll get that
momentarily all right let
me
the as chair of the house waves and
Means Committee I find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of co9 pandemic in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a revenue
work session please note there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen contemporar
ly to this meeting however in accordance
with the emergency order I am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporarily
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporar listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made made avail
aailable in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar in the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with house rules
RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS l.st doh. Us in the event the public
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting to assist
us
Christopher Shay and Brad Greenland
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting should be done
by roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also State whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to no law so representative
Bernstein if you take the
attendance thank you Mr chair and good
morning to you and good morning to
everyone it is March 18 2021 9:05 a.m
and even though it's morning uh Ways and
Means is fortunate to have a number of
stars joining us
[Laughter]
today let's begin the roll call really
Reach For
Those let's begin roll call with
Representative Patrick AB brownie here
in my home in stratum uh I'm
alone substitute uting for
representative Mary Griffin is
representative Judy Aaron welcome to
Ways and Means representative Aaron
thank you good morning I am at home in
aworth uh my husband is upstairs uh
working in his office and my cats are
Milling around
somewhere representative
oy home
wife
house representative obber home in
Hudson with the usual six cats
representative ducet good morning home
alone my home office in Sal your humble
clerk is Alan burin I'm here in
Nottingham New Hampshire in my home
office by myself representative Elliot
I'm here in Salem and my queen of this
kingdom is in the living room and
remember gentlemen when the queen is
happy there is peace in in the Kingdom
Amen to that thank you Al representative
janigian yes I am uh home in Salem and
my wife is somewhere in the house
representative herel Nunes good morning
Mr clerk I'm home alone in pilham
representative Tim
Baxter representative Baxter
representative spillsbury good morning
uh home in Charles Town with several
other family members elsewhere in the
house good morning representative Paul
tutor home in Northwood wife's in the
house representative Susan
Aly good morning um Susan Aly in Lebanon
Home Alone representative Richard
Ames yes I'm here I'm uh in my home
office in Jeffrey alone good morning
representative ases representative Tom
Southward here and over alone
representative Dennis
Malloy home in Greenland uh in by myself
in my home office representative Thomas
shamberg uh representative shamberg is
in wilmet I want to thank representative
Burstein for his upbeat roll calls every
morning uh I'm in my corner office and
my wife is in her office representative
Edith Tucker yes I'm home alone in
Randolph where it's
raining representative Jenny garlo
I'm home alone in Swansea but my husband
will wander through as he usually does
at some
point uh replacing representative Tom
lofman we are very happy to have
representative Marjorie
Smith thank you very much um Mr clerk
I'm uh in Durham
alone representative Connie
Lane I'm here and I'm in my home office
in conquer and I have two family members
elsewhere in the house
and right out of the shower is
representative Mary hackin Phillips good
morning I come to you from my office in
con hello representative James
Murphy good morning Mr clerk I am home
alone in Handover and our esteemed chair
representative Norman major good morning
I'm in my home alone my wife is out
shopping Mr chair there are 23 members
present uh representative baxer I'm
hoping we'll join us
shortly okay that's pretty
good all right uh this morning we're
going to start off with the ND
revenues and then we'll go into the Dr
revenues and then we'll finish up by
going to the legislative changes that
are addressed in
hp2 so Chris and you you have a lineup
for the ndra revenues and who's on first
um I think we could start with Lottery
we have Mr McIntyre on the line he did
he had an engagement he need to get to
once he's done with you guys so if you
could start with Lottery that would be
good and then you have insurance and
liquor and you have travel and
tourism so however whatever order you
want to go after that okay thank
you and
Charlie relative to the estimates for FY
21 22 and
23 do you have any changes from the last
time you gave us the
estimates good morning Mr chairman frog
in the throat um members of the
committee uh Charlie McIntyre Hampshire
lottery um I don't have any changes at
this time I would tell you that the
current estimate for this fiscal year
would be on the more conservative side
now than it had been previously so we
anticipate excuse me talk about timing
um it's possible in a month time we
would raise guidance uh we had an
exceptional uh January which we
transferred into February um which
raised our overall transfer number uh
significantly I think we are 34% had a
plan currently um but that is a
statistically very High number compared
to our comparators so I'm reluctant to
change the number only because we're
such an outlier for the most for all of
New England in terms of our Revenue
growth so um I have no change now but
certainly it's possible it's more than
possible is likely to raise Guidance the
next next time is that
34% I had a plan primarily due to the
um the
lar jackpots that that we had earlier
this
year um it's certainly that did that
didn't hurt that helped immensely um
it's everything we're it's everything um
we're seeing significant growth in
lottery tickets scratch ticket sales um
but it's not Statewide it's the entire
state is up but there are Pockets that
are up significantly more than others
like the Lakes Region for example is up
significantly
um well above 30% in terms of scratch
ticket sales uh and I'd imagine that's
due to a number of citizens who are not
natural citizens of New Hampshire but
sort of um live here now because of
covid and engage in activity that they
did in Massachusetts or Connecticut or
rhod Island up here so um like for
example our lowest region growth-wise is
SE Coast for for another the there's
been not the same level of growth there
has been Lakes Region so um that's the
answer I we're up everywhere Mr chairman
so um it's you know it's good news it's
just scary
news okay then uh the plan was 110.4 for
fy21 yes last mentioned that you
expected it would come in at
12.6 yes are you still holding with that
yes and that actually would now be on
the more conservative side of our
estimates so um I'm more than
comfortable giving that number sir and
then U the same way with fy22 and 23
holding at 125 for
22 yes 27.5 for 23 that's correct okay
questions from the
committee represent elme
thank you Mr chairman uh Charlie if this
is mostly due to Outsiders that are
living among us and likely to go back
isn't it likely they're still going to
be here through June
and without touching 22 and 23 maybe we
ought to be increasing
21 thank you I mean certainly the when I
was visiting with you folks last time
that took into account the large growth
we would experien in January because we
transfer a month behind us you know
representative Aly
um I I'm certainly reluctant to raise
guidance off of a single event which is
historically never been
duplicated
um I don't want to overpromise and
underperform as you can imagine um so I
would imagine certainly I would believe
that would be the case that these folks
would still still be here in June um
it's not all of the growth it's a it's a
it's a large portion of it um but I I
don't want to raise guidance off of
it okay representative Ames followed by
representative
abonne representative Ames you're
muted I think uh representative bramy
was ahead of me but if this is the way
you want to go that's fine I may be I
may be asking your question so why don't
you go first and I'll okay we we'll see
H okay um yeah this is uh and uh Mr
chair
I tell me if this is out of order but uh
this is a question related to House Bill
two and thear horse racing
gaming um new Beyond current law Revenue
estimate that that would be because
we're just dealing with current law then
when once we go into Hill to we can deal
with that
great although although Charlie won't be
with us he's the one who can answer the
question
norm since Charlie be a to view of us um
and go ahead ask question okay thank you
representative Ry um
in your um so I'm I'm asking about the
historic ra racing gaming estimate of
Revenue that um is um likely to appear
in House Bill 2 apparently the value
finance committee is considering
inserting this bill
into house bill two and uh the revenue
that it brings um so uh the estimate
that you have your fiscal note I think
you prepared it um becomes critical um
we need to be sure it's right and uh the
estimate that is being carried
is is basically your estimate I believe
128 or 12.9
million and that would be in fiscal year
23 um and looking at that fiscal note
that the company HP
626 which is the form in which we've
looked at it um you assumed uh
16 locations and uh and an expected
daily handle per terminal and a certain
number of
Terminals and then you did a calculation
that gave you the total gross revenue
called handle the total total handle for
the year and then you took
12% of that as the
takeout and then move from the
takeout to um the distribution amongst
the
various um places that the money goes to
one of them being to the
state um the 12% that you used is the
maximum commission Allowed by house
build 626 and presumably by the what
will be in house build
2 um and uh so um my question to you is
why did you use that
12% um we know from testimony that uh
the other states that do historic
racing um
gaming are
more have a takeout that's more like 8%
Wyoming I just looked at Wyoming it's
about
7.65% and um if you use that as your
starting point of course you get a lower
number for the distributions and I
understand uh from discussions we had
yesterday that you think uh with a a
lower takeout that there would be more
gaming activity so that the gross would
be higher and so it would all work out
but that's a pretty big jump uh of
gaming activity in order to to U come
out at the same point so that's the
that's my question I we need to get this
right and uh um i' like your response to
all
that certainly uh thank you for the
question representative Ames uh
um when you think about gambling it's
not a typical product obviously it's not
like you bought a candy bar at a
community store or a piece of clothing
at a retail shop where it costs so much
to make it costs so much to sell and
there's a
margin
the the handle is really just activity
it's not gross revenue and I I know this
hard to explain but represent name say
for example you and I play poker and I
have $100 and you have $100 we sit at
the table for two hours and play poker
back and forth heads up which means we
play back and forth against each other
we will probably have a handle somewhere
around two or three
thousand because the bets the place I
bet $20 you bet $20 you win you bet $20
I bet $20 I win so the handle is just a
very large number that gauges activity
the the main number is What's the total
commission obviously or what we we what
we characterize in the business as gross
Gaming revenue
ggr and I know this is going to sound
counterintuitive but oddly the lower the
number related to percentage of
commission the higher the net
profitability for
gambling for example the highest payout
state in the US per capita for lottery
tickets is
Massachusetts they are also the number
one state
in net Gaming revenue per capita in the
Free
World
so what you're doing is you are creating
it it's
it's it's the experience it's the I want
I lost I want it lost I want it lost
you've created a lot of activity and and
you've increased the amount
of net revenue and I'll give you another
example New Hampshire we have raised the
prize payout significantly since I
arrived here 11 years
ago and sort of logic if you were a
normal business would you would you
would think well if we raise prize
payout that means we get less of the pie
no we we grew the pie a lot uh our first
year our first year here net revenues
and scratch tickets I think were 35
million whereas this year they're
estimated to be$ 53 million
so um I don't changeed it at all
candidly I would probably raise it if
anything representative Apes if if the
payout is where it's
9% um I would certainly think that those
folks knew what they were doing and
probably raise guidance on it um and I
would sort of remind the committee that
we have been pretty good about Revenue
estimates in the past as to all other G
forms of gambling um you know I don't
say we've never been off but we usually
been pretty right about new forms of
gambling are you all set representes
well I I guess I'm gonna just go a
little further I you know you're the
expert Charlie and I bow to that um and
uh yet in
your huh wish you tell my wife that yeah
right we
can well we could go on about that um so
um when you did your
estimate you did
use a total of expect expected
handle
um and you did that based on a number uh
per terminal and this is how uh Wyoming
calculates their total handle too I mean
there's his
actual um Y and that uh that takes into
account I have to assume all the churn
that you
described um and then with that number
you took 12% of it and went on through
the calculation so you know for me
looking at
this it sure looks like uh the um handle
from the gaming
machine will be
um in that order of magnitude and I do
understand the the suggestion that uh if
uh there's more to be taken can not more
to be kept by the players so less of a
hand handle a share that the might be
more activity I can understand that but
essentially uh I have to using this mode
of analysis that you've given us I have
to assume that the gambling level will
go up by
um
133%
basically so is
your question is yeah so I I I'd just
like the director to respond to
that I mean certainly to your question
um representative Ames the handle is not
a fixed number this isn't a question of
um like I said a a fixed product a
widget which you buy over store um
handle is a factor of a number of things
one of which is payout like for example
if this loss we write the fiscal notes
to correspond with what we know is to be
in the law we don't want to factor in
what may or may not occur in the field
because they'll it'll never be a fixed
number in the field the payout will vary
day by day week by week because some
folks win more on certain days than
other days um so if we were to change
the hand U handle percentage or the if
it was 85% we would write to 80 to 15%
because we know that's the fixed number
in the law versus what we would probably
know to be the industry standard in
terms of payout for the machines um and
I would estimate there somewhere around
91% varying by machine and by location
on the floor but that's the person who
know whose job it is to to dictate where
those go um like I said I I would
suggest to you that this is a
conservative estimate 12.8 million um
and
certainly hearken to our folks in
Wyoming but I don't use their revenue
estimates as a comparator only because
it's such a
desperate State the population density
in Wyoming is a fraction of what it is
here and therefore the activity is a
fraction um I would you know Wyoming is
what bigger than New England I think um
I would expect a large number of folks
to be from Massachusetts who play this
who who do historic racing in New
Hampshire so I count on those customers
to a large
extent okay this okay I think we've
taken it far enough so thank you very
much this discussion has to do house
build to changes due to Historic racing
representative
Bry yeah I just we're we're we're using
20 uh 12 million and then we're using
12.9 million the difference I've gone
with the 12 million figure because about
089 of that is the breakage which goes
to problem gambling I guess the question
for
Charlie I never asked you this is there
indeed a special Fund in which that
money would go to for problem gambling
or is that just become part of your
budget or does the money go to the
general fund um the Council on problem
gaming is administ administratively tied
to us
but they don't work for us like they
they don't work for me we just help them
with administrative functions like
accounting like GNC matters and the like
um so it would be a essentially a line
item boost to
their accounting unit number right so
from which it's is derived from our
budget like our budget I think is
$100,000 goes to them it comes from off
of our line so all that money would go
to the state but it would go to them
right it wouldn't it wouldn't have wind
up in the education trust fund is my
point AB no that it's possible it would
if they didn't spend it so every year if
you so in past years they haven't spent
their allocated budget it revers to the
bottom line and got transferred to
education trust fund Ju Just for the
committee I've I've always used the 12
million assuming that that most of that
would wind up uh going to the that to
that other fund so uh again it's the
breakage that goes there and it's about
point point8 uh about 821 th000 uh so
instead of using the 12.9 that's going
to go to education trust I've I've I've
I've again used the conservative number
of of the 12 million I just want every
understand and again the discussion is
on historic
racing which is part of house build
too all set representative yeah I'm set
just want to know I just wanted to point
that out and thank you for clarifying
that for me Charlie of course of course
represent
again thank you Mr chairman um Mr
McIntyre my question is you may or may
not know the answer to this it may or
may not be something that you track um
I'm wondering if uh when stimulus checks
as stimulus checks come out I heard on
the news the other day that 25% of young
people were spending their stimulus
checks on um the stock market and I'm
just wondering there's probably a
certain percentage of people that will
spend their stimulus checks on on the
lottery um was that anything where you
saw a bump last time stimulus checks
went out and whether you expect any sort
of bump this time along with larger
stimulus
checks I I certainly we saw a large bump
but it wasn't so um we saw a large bump
just globally and it's been staying
there so there hasn't been a time where
we've noticed an
uptick to a specific event um other than
a large jackpot which is our Norm so the
answer is no I haven't seen it um like
that like like like you I understand
your question to be asking I haven't
seen
it okay thank
you representative
Elliott Bob you're
muted thank you Mr chairman Mr McIntyre
it is my opinion that the reasons uh
that the revenues have been increased is
because of the fact that we're when
people are confined for 24 hours uh they
tend to gamble
more uh do my question is do you and
when the uh Corona uh event uh is
solved uh I believe that the uh Revenue
will decrease do you agree with that
statement I certainly the agree with you
the first part of your statement
representative Elliot thanks for the
question um I believe the first part
relates to not having as many
entertainment opportunities or options
as had previously been but I don't know
we'll see a decrease I was as my Revenue
estimate suggest I think you'll see a
flattening
out um rather than a decrease like for
example you know we're so well
Diversified down what we do I would
anticipate sports betting to continue to
grow dramatically annually and that will
more to make up for any loss we may or
may not have on on one of the other
products we sell so I don't think our
overall revenues would increase
sir thank you for your hopeful
statement any further questions of
Charlie on the revenues for 20 one two
and three can I ask one I have my hand
up I represent uh BR uh Charlie um
Sports ping has been going very well um
any any any reports coming out of Maine
or Massachusetts about their them moving
forward with sports Benning as
well I hear more activity from
Massachusetts and thank you for the
question there I think they
filed I lost track I think at 14
separate bills filed for sports betting
in Massachusetts um which seems like a
lot to me um but they're trying to
decide who does what I would imagine
there'll be a version that comes out
that goes to the mass gaming commission
at some point um but I would anticipate
that probably taking through the fall
and really being next winner question um
but certainly it is an issue the vast
majority of our revenues on the mobile
side uh internet side come from New
Hampshire so I'm not as concerned as I
would be um plus we have the benefit of
not having an income tax where Mass
actually hits uh you for six% of your
winnings in Mass so that gives us an
sort of a marketing Advantage as it were
uh you come here you're not going to get
tax from that funny state tax I mean you
obviously owe it back in Mass but that's
on you not us so
um yes mass is an issue but I haven't
noticed it yet bubbling its ugly head
thank you
Charlie all right
um since you won't be with uh with us
this afternoon on historic racing your
estimates for fy22 and
23 say Tak into consideration what goes
to the problem
gam yes certainly um the estimates would
be um full year running would be 12
million um and it would take us several
months to get up in running so you're
probably looking at
fy22 06 million profitability first year
because with fy22 and 12 million FY 23
yes it'll so it'll take us a while go
through R making uh and then obviously
licensing will happen at the same time
um and so that I would estimate that to
be six-month period it it'll vary by a
month or so but I um we've been real
good about getting Folks up and running
in terms of speed uh we launch sports
betting in 35 days which is the fastest
in the US history I think um so uh we
we'll we'll expedite the process do it
thorough but it'll be I'd estimate that
to be the time
period
okay um saying no other questions thank
you Charlie for joining us thank you Mr
chair members of the committee good to
see you
all Chris uh who's up
next R major if you could have the
travel and tourism go um commissioner
Caswell had a conflict at 9:30 so he had
to leave the call but he's left his
director to talk with you that's um
director
haros and I probably didn't say her last
name correctly but she'll correct me
when she gets on the call
F and we all know that
the Corona virus has greatly affected
our travel and tourism and hopefully we
we'll H some good
news good
morning good morning Mrs
hores good morning uh representative me
major nice to see everyone this morning
my apologies that uh commissioner
Caswell had to jump off for another
commitment so you just have me today
sorry about
that
okay
[Music]
questions from the
committee represent major this is Chris
I believe that Lori was going to talk a
little bit about what travel and tourism
has done and some of their strateg IES
for marketing around the state that they
use the travel and tour tourism fund for
to give the committee a sense of um of
of what's being done to try to bring the
the um travel and tourism in New
Hampshire and keep it in New Hampshire
um that was based on the questions that
came up at the last or two a couple
meetings ago so I don't know if Lori
wants to go and present to you first and
then let questions come after that would
be
great super thank you chairman and Chris
for uh setting me up for just uh this
presentation so um just wanted to say
thank you for the opportunity to speak
with you today um I hope you had the
chance to review the information that we
had sent over ahead of time hopefully it
provided some background on our research
but also showed um you some of our most
recent marketing efforts and uh why
travel and tourism is so critical to New
Hampshire's economy um dtds mission is
to promote the state of New Hampshire as
a domestic and international travel
destination in order to increase
visitation and travel expenditures
business activity and employment
throughout the state as I am sure you're
aware travel and tourism was the hardest
hit industry during this pandemic
collectively the industry was forced to
lay off over 40,000 individuals um from
an industry Workforce of about
70,000 while we have slowly recovered
this industry is still very much in
need funding our office will be critical
in helping the industry to the road to
recovery many of them don't have the
resources to Market on their own they
also need to direct their time energy
and budgets to hiring people back buying
inventory and getting their B businesses
uh up and running again they really rely
upon our marketing efforts to bring the
visitors to
them you know experts predict that as
more people are vaccinated consumer
confidence is going to grow creating
great potential for a successful summer
season and Beyond people have pent up
demand to to to get out and enjoy the
things that we used to do I know I do
I'm I'm assuming you do it's just what
we're all feeling right
now at this time do critical
is even more critical that we keep our
foot on the gas and remain competitive
with our neighboring states competition
is going to be fierce coming out of this
pandemic Vermont is looking to raise
their budget to be closer to ours in the
past Maine already has a budget that is
a couple million dollars higher than
ours and before Co began we were gaining
market share on our neighboring states
so let's not lose that positive traction
that we had um accomplished the other
very important fact is our strong return
on investment for this data we use an
independent research firm that is out
outside of our Ad Agency they're called
um smari the acronym but it's strategic
marketing and research insights they are
National a nationally known research
company they do a variety of work for
multiple States um and we've been
working with them for the over the past
five years so we've got a good amount of
data to compare to through their
research which all of our research is is
on visit andh our website and the
industry section so it's available to
the industry and the public but through
our research we conduct advertising
Effectiveness reports from each of our
seasonal campaigns and these reports
tell us the number of people we
influence to travel to New Hampshire as
a direct result of our marketing efforts
the seasonal reports are then used to
complete our um yearly return on
investment in calendar year 2019 over
11.5 million visitors came to New
Hampshire spending $5.6 billion doar and
our fiscal year 2019 research shows that
marketing efforts directly influenced
636,000
generating $33 million in taxes
therefore every marketing dollar spent
$3 is returned in
taxes finally I just wanted to say that
our efforts don't only help the tourism
industry they support the overall future
economy of New Hampshire today's tourist
is tomorrow's Talent the whole concept
of live where you play is even more
prominent now I guess a silver Ling to
the pandemic has been people
re-evaluating life and where they really
want to be and what's important to them
the pandemic has also pushed us to be
more acceptable of a work setting where
you can work remotely and New Hampshire
provides a great backdrop to that so
please I encourage you to help us be
part of this movement and make New
Hampshire the best place to live work
and play in the Northeast um so thank
you for the opportunity to present and
I'm happy to answer questions at this
time
yes we all know that travel and tourism
helps at least six of our major taxes
business
taxes Tobacco
liquor and the big one meals and rooms
and the gasoline tax which supports our
highway to to a great
degree what is your
projection uh for the tra travel tourism
business coming out at the by the end of
the year what percentage do you feel it
will be
back yeah this is a very good question
at this point in time we don't
specifically have any forecasts just
because there so many variables in the
air in regards to the pandemic but we do
we are expecting a very um a profitable
summer season with things beginning to
open up more in uh regulations or
restrictions being eased um and as I
mentioned with the pent up demand of um
Travelers wanting to get out and do the
things that we used to do but at this
point in time I don't have specific
figures that I can share with you on
forecast okay representative
Brony uh thank you Mr chair uh thank you
uh a nice presentation um it seems that
in February our our ski conditions were
very good um every time I fact that it
seemed like the most of the terrain was
open uh do you have any any gauge on how
well the ri area is did this season and
that would
obviously have an impact on the local
businesses and so
forth yeah so uh the you know ant
antidotal uh uh information that we've
received through ski New Hampshire and
percentages of how the ski resorts are
doing you're absolutely right that they
did um have a good season um you know it
was uh with all things considered um but
they did um you know most of the resorts
they had uh full capacity that with the
amounts that they were allowed to have
there so um it does seem as though the
the ski areas did do well this winter
season with all things considered okay
is that probably a good alen for uh the
spring and the summer hopefully yes
hopefully yes we've heard you know just
uh through industry that um a lot of the
um uh like uh businesses throughout the
leak Lakes Region they already have
advanced booking for the summer season
so you know I think that people are
consumer confidence is gaining and
people are can
um imagine themselves going out on
vacation for the summer so they are
beginning to book more frequently now so
okay thank you represent Aly followed by
representative
tar thank you Mr chairman and the one
thing that this conversation is about is
the hp2 language and I don't think that
uh Miss harness uh I'm not sure how you
pronounce
you uh is going to be here when we're
discussing it may I ask a question about
it you may thank you on section 55 page
26 lines 3 to5 of
hb2 suspends all of the tourism
marketing money for two years uh this is
the first time that has happened since
uh I believe uh speaker O'Brien got it
suspended also uh it was in instated in
2009 uh as a tradeoff to the uh
restaurant and lodging people because we
were increasing the ooms and meals tax
to 9% in order to get through the Great
Recession and ever since that was
instated they have been growing at 5% a
year which is
phenomenal and that marketing money is
important most particularly to the media
and smaller Enterprises inside of New
Hampshire because the larger ones could
do their own marketing and sometimes do
on but the others cannot and they are
branding New Hampshire as a destination
in the places that are most
important uh to reach on at the time
like for instance I doubt very much that
they're doing much in Europe because the
Europeans ain't going to be able to to
come so uh and during the Great
Recession they turned their attention
also to our neighboring states down
through New Jersey I think it was and um
got us a lot more tourism and a lot more
of what the chairman has been talking
about in all of our
taxes on and and I would just like to to
um notice and ask uh miss haros about it
uh there on there was a claim that you
get I think it was $13 back for every
dollar uh in ta we get $13 back in taxes
for every dollar that is spent in this
marketing program and
over the years since this was instated
it's been studied by the folks at uh
Plymouth State University and they they
were the last time I saw one of theirs
which was about at least five years ago
on we were getting 8 back so on can you
say something about why the returns
grown yeah absolutely so I think that
you know part of the reason is that we
have become even um better at targeting
our marketing we use different types of
um like arrival lists so that we can try
to find those specific consumers or
visitors that are are interested in what
New Hampshire has to offer so we've been
able to do that um with the um the the
funding that we have had in the past
we've been able to extend our um
marketing efforts and in such places as
you mentioned like New Jersey New York
um and we have uh seen that we've
actually gained market share um in those
markets um specifically like from states
of like Vermont so we're gaining their
visitors that typically are from New
York going to Vermont they're now
choosing New Hampshire to come so um as
part of that um you know people who are
typically coming from a farther distance
um will stay longer they spend more
money while they're here so these are
very good um Travelers for us to Target
so um that's part of the reason of why
the uh the uh return on investment has
grown over uh since 2009 um so hopefully
that that answered your question to some
degree yes thank you I would like to
point out we need to get rid of that
section representative Tucker uh Chris
did you have something I I just wanted
to yeah I did I just wanted to clarify
that section though it suspends the
piece of law
the travel and tourism is still
receiving an
appropriation over the bium they're
they're going to be appropriated about
$17
million so it it's all that all that
suspension is doing is um limiting or or
not binding the governor when he
proposed the the bill um to a certain
appropriation level that would otherwise
need to happen I think it would be a
couple million dollars higher if that
language wasn't there so so I just want
to make it clear to the committee that
that the travel and tourism is being
funded the travel and tourism fund will
have money in it to spend on New
Hampshire promotions um it just may be a
little less than um what would have
occurred under the the law that's being
suspended which has been suspended
pretty regularly by the legislature um
over the last few
bienniums um because again because the
uh the limited resources to apply to all
the different needs around the state
um Governors and legislators have have
made decisions to suspend that piece of
legislation um throughout the throughout
the years um so I just want to make that
clear because I think I heard that they
didn't have any money as a result of
that being suspended and in fact they do
it's just maybe a little bit less than
they would without the suspension so
that's all I
had thank you Chris that on nobody had
had mentioned that to me while I've been
freaking
out my apologies I I probably should
have done that the other day and I just
probably was distracted
so could I just on add on one one
question on that I think would be of
interest to those of us on the committee
before this time they seem to be
deleting the the uh division of of uh
film and digital Bureau of film and
digital
media on and on I think that our
committee would be happy about that but
I'd like to know what you think
about yeah so you know we with with the
state of um where we are we had to make
difficult decisions and so we had to
look at a variety of you know all of our
different programs and what we felt was
um providing the the the biggest return
for us so um you know we do feel that
there is the opportunity for us to still
use um the tourism backdrop drop similar
to what we do within trying to um
encourage today's tourist to be
tomorrow's talent in the economic sense
that we could use tourism on the film
side and through our marketing efforts
kind of um blend it in with that so you
know I think that there could could be
uh we just felt that that was probably
the best way we should should do this
for this year so okay representative
Tucker uh yes thank you for taking my
question uh tell me what are you hearing
from the uh State Parks and Recreation
are the state parks going to be open are
there reservations opening up now for
the summer how how are we coming on that
whole project
for the yes yes thank you representative
Tucker so we do work closely obviously
with state parks I just saw a notice
from them saying about um certain Parks
opening I believe it was you're gonna
have to correct me if I'm wrong but I
believe it was towards the end of April
that they were going to be beginning to
open so that's positive news um we also
are working very closely with them um on
initiatives about um uh you know how we
had issues last year with overcrowding
and um trying to um disperse the the
visitors to a variety of different
locations so that um you know our
natural attributes are um sustained and
people can continue to enjoy them
throughout um years to come so um we are
hoping that state parks will have a a a
profitable and good summer season as
well and open as uh soon as they can
thank you
Elliot thank you Mr chairman and welcome
Lori uh you stated that you don't have
specific figures for us uh my question
is when will you have specific figures
for the State of New Hampshire and its
representativ uh yes thank you
representative Elliot you know for we
don't have the specific figures again
for the forecasting and and ultimately
it's for because of all the variables
that are out there with the p pandemic
um we do work with smari uh the um
research company that I had referenced
typically for these types of forecasts
and as we begin to recover from this
pandemic we would imagine that we would
um begin to to produce those reports uh
as we typically have done in the past so
I don't have a specific date to to give
you that we would do that but um we're
hopeful that we'll we'll be doing that
um soon again as we as we recover from
the pandemic thank you any further
questions ask see none we thank you for
coming before the committee this morning
thank you for the
time and Chris uh who do we have next
why don't we go with insurance I know
there's a number of people on the um
attendees list from insurance you have
the commissioner nicolopoulos and Norma
St ings Deputy Commissioner
rice and um maybe Amy doam may need to
come into the call as well if I anybody
the commissioner can let us
know who wants um who wants to start off
from the insurance department Ro
status ready go uh Chris nickop here I'm
just going to do a quick intro and defer
to our expert noral stalling I think
Christy rice is here as well in case
either of us missed something uh as you
probably know this is a busy week for us
uh as of Monday all of our premium tax
was due uh that's typically uh north of
a100 million and so though NOA doesn't
have audited numbers for you yet I think
she's going to be able to give you a a
preview on what that looks like and
updates for uh 22 and 23 so I'll pass it
off to Norma but I'll stay on in case
you have any
questions
okay nor how how do we look for
estimates for 22 23 and
24 okay you want
uh
22 we originally projected uh 127
million uh based on what we see
currently coming in for fiscal year 202
21 I would uh give you a range from the
127 million up to 130
million uh again they that's for 21 this
oh this is for 22 I thought you wanted
22 the 21 was back up then in like I say
the estimates originally back in
November we had anticipated the impact
of the auto paybacks and the
unemployment as well as a shift in the
health um premium Market would impact
downwardly what we would see but is as
it turns out there's been a very small
impact to the um Auto and the increases
have have been in various
lines and as an end result overall we
have a
3.6% increase in our tax base so for
fiscal year
2021 actually we're looking at closer to
what our original authorized budget of
million so that would go from what you
gave us before 128. two that would go up
to
13.9 yes I I currently again we haven't
audited all of these uh returns we're
still sorting things out and there's a
number of
uh other factors in the reconciling that
hasn't been done yet but at this point
in
time I'm looking at and this is after we
make our transfer to the Department of
Health and Human Services approximately
131 million for fiscal year 2021 okay
and then
2022 2022 again
because the if if all things remain calm
and then
proove that we should see at least the
127 million originally budgeted possibly
up to 13 30
million
2022 so are you going to stick with your
127 well again I'll give you the range
right now in uh best case scenario would
be up to 130 million 127 to 130 okay yes
and then on 23 on 23 again our original
uh anticipated budget authorized was 13
3.3
million I believe it potentially again
if everything still continues in this
upward Trend it could potentially be 135
million so would you
say a range from
133.33
correct okay questions from the
committee representative
bronley uh thank you Mr chair uh thank
you for your testimony um so if we took
the midpoint would that be pushing
it uh for 22 and
23 no that's that that's probably a
reasonable best
estimate do you feel comfortable that
it's probably going to exceed the
original numbers
well again if if everything
continues in the positive
trend I would anticipate that what we
had
projected was was you know very
conservative okay that that's very
helpful thank you you're
welcome any further questions
speaking of positive
Trends the Federal Reserve just came out
this
morning and and Ro and increased their
gross domes
product to
6.5% for 21 and 3.3% for
22 and that compares a forecast of 4.2%
and 3.2% so they've increased their
growth rate in in both years
2122 any further questions of asked to
ask of the insurance department see none
we thank you for coming
in that was easy enough
okay thank you
all have a good day Chris who's on yes
you you have the Liquor Commission
they're the last agency um before you
get Dr and um the house bill to stuff
so
okay morning Mr
chairman good
morning my name is Joseph Mo I'm the
chairman of the newshire commission with
me this morning and you're going to up
update us on what you
anticipate the liquor revenues are going
to be for fy21 22 and 23 we are prepared
to do that Mr chairman yes we are so and
with me is our CFO Tina deers uh we have
handed you uh a handout that has the
updated Revenue Trend I can't hear you
that well
okay that has the updated Revenue Trends
and transfer language on it on page two
and Tina will walk you through that and
then we'd be happy to answer any
questions that you may
have nor I have that Norm representative
major I have that I have that sheet I
don't know if everybody else does is it
possible for them to put their document
on on the screen yeah can you put that
up Chris yes I can repent major one
moment everybody should see it I have it
on page two um unless Tina wants me to
go back to the first
page fine thank you
pres good morning um you will see on in
the col
uh FY 2021 on row s we are still
projecting our Revenue estimates at 12
129 million which is plan if you go to
the column for fy22 and 23 if you look
at Row
three the general fund transfer our
estimates for fy22 are
138.3mm is currently in the plan
currently it's
136.6 and
136.34 million and FY 23 by 2.1
million and that's based on our current
sales
Trends our questions from the
committee
Norm representative Bry yeah um in our
in our on our summary we we had to beer
tax at 3.2
million yes is that
is is that remain it looks like you've
lowered it to
13.1 uh we had originally projected the
13.1 and it was put in plan at the
13.2 um the beer tax fluctuat anywhere
between like 12.9 and the 13.2 so the
13.2 could be
attainable it's fairly flat
representative as it goes along over the
years it doesn't change it doesn't
necessarily change a lot it's a couple
hundred thousand either way right I
understand thank you I I I guess I just
saw that change I was trying to
understand if it's it's not really that
material but um you know I guess guess
we just have to decide if we want to use
the original 3.2 or the 3.1 that's all
it's been pretty flat over the years yep
representative
elme thank you Mr chairman on the
granite Advantage transfer um I thought
that they were going to come back and
ask for more that would have come out of
this has that been ruled out or is it
just not
yet
and you'll see on uh row six we did
transfer that additional 8.5 million so
to dat we've transferred 18.5 million
they haven't asked for any more
additional money other than
that thank you so that was an additional
to the first 10 corre that's
correct represent
Ames um I I'm not sure what your number
is for fiscal year 21 what are you
showing here for that if you look on row
seven it's the we have
1285 um in the plan it's 129 so you know
the 129 is
reasonable
okay good thank
you and 138 point3 for
22 that's
correct and
23 Mr
chairman represent El me I have another
question now um
$1,500,000 has been taken out of their
profits uh for granite Advantage this
year and
that means that there's about um that
their higher numbers for 22 and 23 are
actually about $8 million short of what
they got this year is that
so well you'll see the fy22 and 23
numbers are based on the law of the 5%
that we have to transfer of gross profit
it doesn't include any additional funds
that they might need for the granted
Advantage because we won't know for
those years so if you look down on um
row seven you'll see that our transfer
for fy22 is $8 million higher than our
fy21
number so if I could could ask to
clarify so it is in the permanent
statutes that you're going to be
transferring 5% of your profits to
granted advantage that's correct
representative thank you you're
welcome further questions to ask the El
commissioner all
right so
then for 21 it's 28.5 million for liquor
transfer 22
[Music]
138.3mm yes sir that's correct Mr
chairman all right I see no further hand
Mr yeah just a quick uh I think you said
128.57
from the
commission right that's correct we said
that the
129 um in current plan is
attainable it's very hard to
you the 129 that's currently in plan we
said was
attainable and that
128.57 point5 but we said that the the
plan of 129 would be
attainable wait a
minute
so your line is not your plan is that
correct sorry Mr chairman I didn't hear
you can you am I the only one having
problems hearing oh no it's very hard to
hear we need to have uh they're saying
is that on the they can live with the
129 correct okay original
estimate now on
22 you going to live with the 1366 or go
to
1383 yeah okay and then on
23 the same thing say you're going to go
to
1384 correct
okay hey we are in syn now that's good
perfect any further
questions thank you we're coming
in thank you Mr chairman Chris what do
we have do we have any other agencies
coming in uh not for ND related revenues
um you do the Dr on the call ready to
address any questions you might have um
related to House Bill two or the
revenues you discussed yesterday um
however you want to
proceed I want to proceed with the
business tax
revenues with the
Dr if they could go over that
again uh specifically using as a
reference their March
10th Revenue
estimates if they would go through and
give us an explanation
again there's two types of
abnormalities associated with
21 one is that caused by the uh feds in
the state moving their collection of
taxes last
year and that resulted in the business
taxes of 18.3
million
as tributed to
2020 and then this year there was a $10
million other one time
event now the
18 the
817 million has
shown in
fy21 that is clear of any
normalities first
question good morning Mr chair members
of the committee for the record Melissa
Rollins senior Financial Analyst at
Department of
Revenue so the 817 and
841 is net of the fiscal year 21
anomalous receiv receivable of the 18.3
million it is not net of the 10
million of anomalous tax notice payments
that we received in February
okay
so when we go from U 21 to 22 we have to
remove the $10
million and and the base would be
807 no the low
and
831 for the
high is that correct that's correct when
growing um 22 using that as a 21 base
okay so you want to keep that 10 million
in 21 because we did receive that pay
those payments but you want to remove it
when growing to 22 because we don't
anticipate seeing that those $10 million
payments again in
22 okay represent major this is Chris
would you like me to share that document
so everybody in the committee can see it
please
it's nice to
have great people around knowing what
needs to be
done so you should you should see the
document now and in the note up above
you you do see that the Dr does discuss
removing the 10 million from the 817 and
the 841 when growing it for 22 and
23 and the
18.3 does not show up the 817 it's been
removed that's correct correct
yeah Mr
chairman yes represent could I ask Chris
do we I can't remember do we have to put
the 18.3 into what we present uh in
hr12 uh no no you you remove that from
your house
resolution because it's it's money
that's going to be credited back to
fiscal year 20 but because we're on a
cash basis you see it in the reports
that come out currently but at the end
of the year it will be reconciled and it
won't be in the final revenues for for
21 thank you so it's correct to to
remove it now in your in your work and
that's what Dr has done in their
estimates for us is they' they've
removed those that total of .8 million
in those Revenue sources that had that
um anomalous receivables that came in 21
that should have been done in 20 fiscal
year
20 hopefully that answers and if uh
Melissa or anybody else needs to jump in
and clarify even more I I'll defer to
them I think you hit it on the head
Chris thank you
Melissa so for fisal year
21 the gr has
817 for their low which includes the 10
million and 841 for their High which
includes the 10 million but as we go
from 21 to 22 we remove that 10 million
on both the low and the high to project
for the low and the high for
is that clear with
everybody questions representative
browny yeah I just want to say that uh
the revenue Focus has been footnoting
all of these over the last couple of
months allthough the an anomalous um
Revenue so it's pretty clear that it's
going to go back to the last year's
numbers and uh I think most of us now
that we've clarified this I think the
numbers when you look at the whole
numbers not the percentage increases or
anything like that that these numbers
are are accurate from the Dr uh
hopefully everybody had the same
understanding as was within this report
because we did a lot of work already in
estimating and I just I just want to get
a sense that is anything changed here
that would change anybody's mind on the
estimate that they came up with so
that's just a general question
question uh but it didn't change my mind
I think I think I use what the DR had
here and now we just reverified that
it's yes it's
accurate um so hopefully others feel the
same way okay representative
Bernstein thank you Mr chair
representative Amy just referenced
hr12 and I thought we were working on
hr11 is hr12 a new iteration of hr1 oh I
I beg pardon I couldn't
remember got it so it's just hr11 which
is on the table right now and we're
going to bring that off the table for a
new resolution once we complete our
es and to let you know what's really
going to happen we're working like we're
going to come up and and amend
hr11 but
since we won't be
meeting as a as the house group until
April we need to transfer our Revenue
estimates to finance like
tomorrow and so we need to
um come up with our best projections
with what we know at this point in time
to give the finance knowing that the
heavy months of March is not over and
the heavy month of April April hasn't
happened yet
we'll probably change the estimates and
we're going to go through the same
process again towards the end of
April I appreciate the clarification
thank
you Mr chairman yes
representative I would hope that we
would find a way you would find a way to
uh present the revenue estimate
um before the budget was presented on
the 6th or sth 7th of of April so that
on we would have a fig Leaf left of the
tradition that that has been driving the
revenue estimate going into the
budget yeah at the point in time that we
have when we meet again in April we
should have a
resolution
and then that and then may will be
reading
again and and we'll be meeting again in
June before commencing the committee
conference uh represented
ases okay um Mr chair is this the time
to examine this this uh estimate for
fiscal year
21 uh yes yes it is okay you right
here yeah so what I guess I want to say
first that
I um I've come up with quite a different
number than Dr so I'll give you my
bottom line and then
explain um if I
may go ahead your Nam Okay so
my bottom line when I go through the
calculations that I'm going to take you
through um takes me to 845 million for
fiscal year 21 okay all right so how do
I get there um February
collections before removing the
18.3 amount to $463.30
chis that's uh in the uh monthly report
that Chris sends to us of
collections um that does not have the
18.3 removed so I removed that and my
number after February starting the
beginning of March is
$45.39 now at March 18th and thanks to
dr's uh quickness on this uh we have the
money that has been collected as well as
the
refunds um through to through this
state and those collections are
surprisingly
High um
through March
18th the total
collections reported are amount to $11.2
million the only the the refunds have
been very limited
0.9 so the net collected so far is $1.3
million it's a lot of money
um then we have from the um from the
same report that Dr sends out the amount
that has has been collected um in
previous years well last year as the Dr
report shows last year's collections for
the remaining days of
March so just last year this was just as
the pandemic was hitting by the way and
these are most significantly the
Partnerships that are
filing um for those remaining days in
March uh another $23 million came in
last
year if you take the 100 100.3 that has
that's already in hand for March and you
and to be uh optimistic you put in the
entire 23 that was received last year
for these remaining days you get for
March $123
million so I add $123 to the
445 that uh is the post February period
amount and I get $
5683 million so the question now is what
about April May and June um we obviously
have no nothing uh that's current for
this year until it's till we get into
those months um looking back Beyond we
have to look back Beyond last year
because now we're into Co and the defer
delays of uh tax reporting and all the
other things that happened but for the
previous two years um for those three
months added together 2019 it was $292
Million 20 2018 it was $311
Million if you average that you get
301 and if you add the 301 to the
5683 you get $ 869.485
started this that I'm putting in 845 so
I'm discounting to be uh on the side of
caution um and I know that uh we don't
know what's going to happen in April May
and June but I do know and we all know
that uh the uh business returns payments
revenues have been remarkably good and
particularly um as we've added these
critical months of February March April
May and June um so I think
845 is a conservative
number um and to State the obvious
there's some level of uh uncertainty
about it I also want to say one other
thing I know that the uh uh back in 2019
and 2018 there were anomalous payments
received although most of the big
anomalous payments came in
um in the earlier months and remember
we're just looking at the months um but
I also know that we have uh enacted into
our law um a number of changes to the
business
tax um that have enhanced our
collections at least that's what we
expected we have conformed to the
federal tax code in several particulars
that uh we predicted would increase our
our our collections
and uh we also
um
um well those are the main things I I
guess I should emphasize so that's
that's what I wanted to
say thank
you rep representative
Bron yeah thank you representative Ames
I followed your logic there the the one
question though that I have and maybe
this is also for the
Dr is we're comparing uh runner rates
here on this
report uh what we don't know is is
whether 2000 uh
whether
uh March of
2020 was running below
budget is any is anybody on from Darry
or uh from or maybe Chris I don't have
that right in front of
me
um we're we're we're we're just
comparing run rates but we don't know if
last year's Runway rate was good or bad
or below what we expected because of the
pandemic Melissa can you respond to
that sure so I just pulled up the March
Revenue Focus for last year just to make
sure we're on the same page um and it
looks like business taxes ended
17.5 million below plan
and I I think that's primarily due to
the shift in due date so if you remember
last year um actually the 18.3 million
that we were just talking about last
year the due date was shifted from March
and April into June um and then we know
that taxpayers ended up paying in July
which was the Federal due date which is
that 18.3 million of anomalous
receivable that got tossed back into
so if it wasn't all of that the the
1029 would probably be 17.5 million more
when I look at the the end of the
so so what you're saying is it really
was a 17.5 million shortfall
I which I think that says something I I
I don't know
um that I I I agree with you the
revenues look look
good but when you compare it against
what March budget was well it doesn't
look as
good is my only
point Thank
you any
other so
um we have the Dr
their high would be
841 and their low is
887 and that
841 hold on one
second contains that $10 million right
is that correct
Melissa that's
correct
and what you're saying representative
Ames your analysis shows
that uh what is your height because you
came out of
145 I mean four 845 what is your yeah
that's a good question I so my 845 is 3
million below what I'm
seeing or is it let's see no it's it's
it's it's it's significantly wait a
minute
I am looking at the wrong numbers so the
high that uh of 841 is what Dr has right
and mine is 845 so there's not much
difference so your 845 is is your high
it is my number yeah I I could go higher
given that I seem to have by my by this
mathematical calculation I
uh there's a basis for going higher I
have chosen um to cut back a little bit
by uh by sort of reducing by $25 million
it's totally arbitrary I recognize that
but uh from the numbers I otherwise get
by the
mathematical comparison with the
previous years is sort of some some
discomfort with those previous years
that I think leads me to do that no
discomfort with What's happen this
year
um represent Al followed by
representative
BR thank you Mr chairman um I think this
is back to Melissa again um
representative abrami seems to think
that on what we're talking about is that
the 17 point five million would have
been in March's on results last year if
um if the we we hadn't had the delay in
people paying what would the March
number really have looked like last
year that is a great question and I do
not have that in front of me um
if I look at one second so we were 17 A5
million B behind March of last
year and we
were
57.9 million for April of last
year and let me just look at June real
quick because that's when payments were
due and we were short 35.2 million in
June so I don't think the
18.3 my my guess off the top of my head
is not much of that 18.3 would have
supplemented
March uh it probably would have more
supplemented April in June um so I would
say March probably would have been a
difference of a couple million so maybe
15 million down just just a quick
assumption based on the loss to
April if that makes sense to you thank
you and at that point did you think that
uh the pandemic was affecting the the
payments I think in March and April our
assumptions were that the payments were
just being delayed until
June uh I think we anticipated we were
going to see more payments in June and
then the July situation happened so we
saw some of those but but after
realizing it the pandemic definitely
affected affected payments because
otherwise we would have seen that 18.3
million be much larger or the payments
in June should have exceeded planned by
a significant
amount if I could just briefly follow up
uh
do we have I can't remember do we have
data on what happened to the credit
carry forward did was more of it used at
that
point um I don't have specific data for
that but it did grow from um 19 to
fiscal year
20 uh so it did increase and that does
go through June
30th but as for the specific months if
in March April and June they used more
CCO I don't have that
data yeah I think we got to move this
forward um I I I respect
uh representative ames's
analysis uh I would need more time with
it to feel more comfortable with it but
that's the Democrat number uh what we've
done in the past is we looked at
Republican numbers 82
7.9 which is 17.1
below uh the Democrat number I have no
problem just splitting the difference
like we have in the past uh that'll
bring our number up and and and Dick's
number down uh to to move this forward
because we can debate back and forth
about this uh I would suggest that
that's what we
do I didn't get the uh your
number our number is
uh uh 8
27.9 which is 17.1 below your
number so if we split the
difference the average the the new
number would be uh 8
83745 right 83 836 837 as compared to
last uh February's number of
89.8 is what was in the uh resolution so
it would be an increase of uh 26.6
million from the original resolution
from uh
February do you have any problems with
thats I don't think I do I think that uh
you know in in this business we we end
up uh splitting the difference and this
is another example of that and we are
actually not that far apart
um but maybe others would want to chime
in when they get the economist together
we'll have a rain and they'll end up SP
aaging at
yeah no put set Economist that you put
together something as diverse as the
business taxes we all agree in one
number and but they'll
be and they end up averaging
it um who else wants to chime in
on
fy21
numbers rep Brown you have your hand up
oh no that was from before
sorry and if we if we do that we would
come out with uh the average of one of
845 and
27.9 is that correct yes yeah I think I
think it comes out to 837 would be what
I would say be
837 if you that's rounding a little bit
but um yeah that's fine
8370 or or yeah okay hey
37 and then we can use the
percentages then we have to then we have
to back out the 10 don't forget that yes
yes so as we forward we'd be using
827 and then agree on percentage
increase going to 22 and then to
23 well the norm uh we went through a
process both the Democrats and
Republicans went through a process
yesterday where we we've gone through
that we we estimated our midpoint are
high and a low than our midpoint uh that
I'm sure the Democrats did something
similar uh so just if we're replicating
what we did last in
February uh I think those are the two
numbers that are in play and then we
have to decide if we want to uh
compromise in the middle
or where where we want to
compromise Mr chairman do that or or we
could agree on percentages what
represent
Aly thank you I I just wanted to
advocate for agreeing on the percentages
because we get further and further apart
on if we aren't using the same
percentages and I want if I could to ask
uh Melissa yesterday um I think it was
you told us that you're going to have to
think about the growth rates for this
next year which starts in a few months
on in terms of what's been going on in
the economy which is what's been going
on in the economy is what's been
changing our minds about what we just
did so you had it at 1 to three%
and I was wondering if for 23 changing
nothing in 20 for 22 changing nothing in
23 if um two to 4% was within your realm
of
consideration knowing that you don't
have all the data for March yet much
less
April yeah thank you for your your
question representative Aly um we have
not dug into this you are correct
however uh I did I think I heard heard
representative major speak earlier I'm
looking down at my notes that they did
increase
GDP um for 2021 to 6% is that correct
representative
major
yeah and if if that six and a half% for
21.3%
22 so that being said when we were
looking at our growth rates before we
were relying on GDP and slowing it down
in 2022 a little bit based on when
timing comes in for returns and how
taxpayers will reflect their funds and
then in
2023 so I I think um without further
analysis but based on that information
if we do think GDP is growing and I want
to look at some other sources too then I
think we would be
comfortable maybe expanding that range a
little bit to to two to 4% I think the
only hesitation I have a little bit and
I would want to dig into it is just
where 21 does land um representative
Ames definitely had some good points and
March is looking good right now um my
only caution for March is we do have um
some refunds still coming out that
haven't been reflected so that number
does go down
some but if 21 comes in higher than
expected and meaning we're recovering
quicker than expected do we still think
22 will continue that growth of two I
think you said 2 to 4% or are we feeling
some of that growth already right now so
just some things that are running
through my mind quickly as we're
thinking about thinking about this but
where we're at 1 to 4% and you saying
two to to 4% with GDP going up I don't
think is outside the realm of
possibilities and and the Democrats had
um raised it from 1 to 3% to two to 4%
and taken the median when we were doing
ours um that is um 3% growth for the
taxes not not the not the economy the
economy is going on now and last year
but um the the tax is on going up three
3% in 22 and then holding on to the four
to
six% uh
in in
23 and when we did
it we went up to 2.1%
from 21 to
22 which
is just about right in the middle
between one and
three no did you take the 10 million out
of that when you did that math yes
okay we went up
3%
yeah but now uh we're our starting point
different at 8:37 with the base being
8:27 we went up 2% on that that's
bring it up to 8:40
something um somebody else want to weigh
in on what they fig well n number
one do we all agree of a starting point
of
837 with that 10 million in there
if you don't agree I want to say a
raised
hands with no raised
hands representative SPS spillsbury
uh thank you Mr
chairman I don't have a crystal ball so
I I won't say anything
assertively but I admire Melissa
rollin's careful way of explaining
things to us and I think
her her observation about representative
Ames
845 which happens to be higher than dr's
high was that it's not outside the realm
of
possibilities so let's grant
that but is something which is not
outside the realm of
possibilities a a reasonable basis for
forecasting seems high
and so that's why take the average of of
both and
the is not as not as
high was higher than what we would have
been so would
you come up with something different
than the
837 well I guess what I'm suggesting to
our Democrat friends is if 845 is
effectively their midpoint and their
midpoint is north of the dr's high do
they want to reconsider that figure
before we go ahead and average the two
I'm perfectly fine with avering two
okay Dave um I mean
de represent ases do you have any
comments on
that well I guess I at first say I
thought we' gone through this discussion
um uh and just I I believe that the
Democrats considered the Dr high as well
as it's low when we discussed this um in
caucus and uh have continued to think
about it ever since then as I have um
and uh I when I uh was uh discussing
this yesterday I didn't uh
realized that my my train of logic took
me even higher than U where I had I was
coming down um so as I say I've locked
off $25 million from where this takes us
to I'd also note with regard to the Dr
High number they've made quite clear
that they have not Revisited their
estimates other than um to take into
account the February number uh so they
haven't gone through through uh
internally a process that revisits um
and Melissa can correct me if I'm wrong
about this but uh going through the kind
of discussion we're going through right
now uh that looks at um performance
since the receipt of that February
number and how that February number
should affect uh
forecasting so yes I'd stand on this
number represent
uh thank you Mr chairman um I would just
say um I am very comfortable with the
837 as a
compromise fine and should we
uh take a vote on this or some got any
other
recommendations if
not why don't we take a vote on the
837 that would set the tone for going to
22 and 23
only on the business
taxes so
um I'll make I'll make the motion that
on business taxes for
fy21 will come in at 8 $ 37
million as a compromise and I'd second
that any other Mr chairman can we go
into gallery view if we're going to do
voting
Chris
poll so the motion has been made 837 for
FY 21
for the business taxes and second by
represent Ames any further
discussion say no further discussion
I'll ask the cler to call the
RO thank you Mr
chair uh let's begin the roll call vote
everyone's clear on the on the the
motion
no okay the motion is for business tax
revenue our projection for 2021 will be
$837
million let's begin the roll call Vote
with uh Patrick abami representative
abrami
yes representative Aon
yes representative oy
yes representative obber
yes representative duet
yes clerk votes yes representative
Elliot yes
representative
janigan
yes representative Nunes
yes Baxter yes spillsbury
yes
tutor yes trying to get my camera back
on Aly yes
Ames you're muted sorry yes yeah
Southworth yes Malloy yes shamberg
representative shamberg votes yes Tucker
yes
garlo yes Smith
Lane yes hackin Phillips
yes
Murphy
yes chairman major
yes CH the vote is 24 to love the motion
carries okay and now we can go on to
fy22 and FY
23 and um let's try the percentage
change
firstes Mr
chair represent major representative
brownley uh is is Chris going to record
this in the uh sport sheet yes okay
thank you Chris you're you're doing that
right yep I'll as you guys make final
decisions I'll put them in a spreadsheet
that I can share when as you get
going only share one screen at a time
though so which one do you want me
to we I think we're good with you just
just recording not do any okay leave it
as is and you let me
know Mr
chairman yes representative BR I mean I
thank you Mr chairman on I just
calculated
2.5%
growth on as as an uh compromise and
that one comes to 8
47.7 million with from
827 8
47.7 yeah
oh wait a minute should it have been
820 no no that was something else yeah
827 times 2.5% someone else wants to do
it well 837 times 1. no 8
827 we have to take out 27 right right
sorry mistake
times 827 time
1.025
847.0135 interestingly
enough uh again to me we're changing the
rule a little bit because I thought we
were going to do it the way we did it
last time so Republicans came up with
8351 Democrats had come up with
860 uh so guess what the midpoint is
if we use the midpoint of the
Republican uh work yesterday and the
Democrat work yesterday that average is
847.011 on the old number right um but
we're starting
with a different number any other
question uh questions or comments on the
8 47.7 for
fy22 saying
none
then repr Aly you want to make a
motion uh you don't want to try and do
them
together I was going to but uh yeah we
can we do them one at a time
I'll I'll make a motion for uh
clerk to call the rooll call the vote
thank you Mr chair uh just to repeat the
motion it is for business taxes the
projection for business taxes in 2022 to
be
yes burin votes yes Elliot yes janigian
yes nunz yes Baxter yes
spilsbury yes Tudor yes
Aly yes Ames yes Southworth yes Malloy
yes
shamberg representative shamberg votes
Tucker yes go Marlo yes Smith yes
Lane yes hackin Phillips yes Murphy yes
chairman major
yes 24 to nothing chairman
major vote been 24 to nothing the
estimate for fy22 is $847 7 million was
going to um FY
23 um point of order chairman if I may
yes represent s the only thing I'm
looking at on the chart is our estimates
were
809 before for 21 then they went up to
826 this time we're going from 837 to
8:47 so I'm just wondering if something
went off a little with the math
well the 837 you have to re remove $10
million and then a two and a half%
increase it brings you up to 847 okay
and did we somehow not do that when we
did the uh February
estimates because it just seems strange
that it goes from 809 all the way up to
826 and then it goes only from 837 to
847 believe when we did the February
estimates is that we didn't have that
$10 million okay so that's that's
another change thank
you um
okay first of
all the r uh increase
of we need to settle on a percentage
increase going from 22 to 23
I I need somebody to step to the
plate before do that says from four to
six%
before represent major before I do that
I I have a a question I want to
ask so you know we we went through the
exercise a week ago sound like a broken
record here uh about the uh single sales
Factor um I made sure in the Republican
caucus um kind of like a broken record
like I said and we we we assumed in our
number uh that the uh single sales
Factor uh was in
place so that we took the our lower
estimate
uh because the $20
million uh issue
because as of now Finance is going to
put uh our bill into the
hb2 put a hold
on it's gonna add 20 million to
revenues because of single sales Factor
because of single sales Factor so I know
the Democrat number is
um uh I just want to know if if that 903
included uh the elimination of the
single sales factor or included the
single sales
Factor um representative gramy or
representative uh Mr chair is it okay if
I ask a question go ahead represent I I
guess I didn't hear maybe it was said
what what your Republican caucus number
was for this year what was uh eight
59.8 lower than than the de you know
than the Democrat number of
n was there an assumed rate of growth
and then a subtraction of some number
for single sales or how did you do it no
we we did it we just did high low each
member each member gave us high
low uh we took the average of the highs
the average of the lows and then took
the
midpoint
and that assumed that it was current law
so
we took a more conservative number
thinking that single sales Factor would
be in place by
23 um so if if that wasn't the case our
number would be $20 million
more it'
be88
79.8 right because we have taken into
consideration the single sales Factor
which is getting going to be put back in
in House Bill
two think
right Mr
chairman yes our number was created by
adding a 5% growth rate okay so we are
no longer at the same number in 22 so on
our number from there would be lower um
than
93 and I believe that we did forget the
single sales
factor I look like you did
because and as far as the finance
committee goes House Bill
two with the delay of using House Bill
house B
281 is a $20 million advantage and it
puts it back in
so we lose it in our numbers because
it's law current
law and in house build two because we
we're going to
defer a few more years the single sales
Factor you can put it back
in our number should
reflect the single sales Factor $20
million yes and I think um if if if we
we have now adopted the uh
[Music]
that's
better
and okay so 5% growth on
doing a calculation here so so
Republicans were at 8 59.8 Democrats
were at 870 if we took the midpoint if
we want to do it that way
again on representative agami our
position was the
5% on top of of
22 and 22 has changed
so they aren't
comparable the the business taxes are
different
because
we we remot $20
million because of the single sales
factor is current
law but in HB 2 we we're going to put
$20 million back because we're going to
delay the S Sales Factor so two numbers
should be the same in both
sides so I have no problem taking the 88
47.7 multiplying by 5% and reducing it
by the $20
million you saying you're okay with the
870 Norm yeah
yes to offer yes has his hand
up thank you represent major I just
wanted to um remind the committee that
with your estimates that you do today
under under current law we would include
those in and House Bill one under the
unrestricted
revenues so these would be under current
law pure anything related to House Bill
two so if there's a change related to
revenues as a result of a house bill two
section that would be accounted for in
the Surplus statement it would show up
on the Surplus statement it wouldn't
show up in your Revenue estimates that
you come up with
today so I I just want to make sure that
you guys as you're figuring out like
you're bringing up the um single sales
factor that 20 million will be shown on
a surplus statement it won't be shown in
the unrestricted revenues that are
contained in house bill one
because yeah I think we've got that
that's clear and that's good to have it
yes said so clearly um so I think what
we're talking about now is
87.1 um as a possible compromise number
is that do I have it right
87.1
I I can I can I can do without the 0.1
if it makes it
easier
870 yes I can I can live with that I
don't know about everybody else okay
anybody else have any other way they
want to figure this
out see none than us for a motion for
the $870
million
if there's silence I'll I'll jump in I
I'd be happy to move U
87.0
million as the estimate for FY 23
FY FY 23 right and seconded by who Pat
ABY okay so the motion on the floor is
FY 23 business revenue of 87
million made by
representative am seconded by
representative AB
bronley there any further discussions or
questions on this if not I seeing none
so representative Bernstein would you
call the vote on this sure thank you Mr
chair if everyone's clear on the motion
we'll begin the roll call with
representative abrami yes
Aaron yes
ory yes Ober yes duet yes bin votes
yes yes thank you janigian that's
twice Nunes yes maxter yes spillsbury
yes
tutor yes Aly
yes names yes Southworth yes Maloy yes
representative shamberg representative
shamberg votes yes Tucker thank you yes
Marlo yes
Smith sorry
yes
Lane yes hackin Phillips yes Murphy yes
chairman major yes Mr chair the vote is
24 to nothing the vote being 24 to
nothing the
motion of ought to pass for FY 23
revenues for business taxes is $870
million that's going to be that's our
toughest one the business
taxes because we medic and caucuses as
Republicans and Democrats and then last
night representative alamy and myself we
compared the rest of our work and the
rest of our work is pretty close so it
should be pretty easy at this point in
time I want to take a five minute
break and we'll be
back in five
minutes
oh
for
long
you
for
[Music]
okay
okay looks like most of people are
back I think we can change the procedure
a little bit now
so because we got the tough tough one
out of the
way
I'm waiting for
Allan back oh represent
Bernstein there he
is all right
um we looked at the revenues as a
whole and we knew the business taxes
would be the most
difficult and then uh the next one would
be the meals and
rooms and then the
uh the
IND I'm sorry the
re the real estate taxes
so what I
suggest and after talking with
representa Aly last
night let me go through this on the mees
and woms tax on FY
21 the Republican midpoint was
31.8 the Democrats was
and almost like the same and I would say
I would suggest that um
we go with a
311 on
fy22 the Republican midpoint was
34.5 the Democrats was
342 I would suggest we go to
on FY
23 the Republicans midpoint was 360.
one the Democrats is
359 I would suggest
go
360 and
uh does anybody have a problem with
that almost as if we were watching each
other
um so then what I would
do is make a motion
that the revenues for meals and rooms
for
2021 be 311
million
322 to be $341
million and 323 would be $360
million I'll second
that what was that let me say those
again
311 for
341 for
22 and
360 for
23 I'll make that representative am
seconded it who seconded it Ames repr a
okay
we have any discussion on
this can I just make one comment nor
bronz so that would be that would this
would make it 10 million for two
20121 10 million higher than February's
estimate uh 22 13 million and
23 uh 10 10.5 million yes
and we were think thinking that there
was never going to be an end an end to
the co pandemic so things change just a
matter of
months any further discuss or questions
on that
motion saying none I'm going to
ask representative Bernstein to call the
vote
thank you Mr chair if the question is
clear to everyone we'll begin the roll
call Vote with Representative Patrick
abramy yes representative Judy
Aaron unmute and one more time
Judy you have to unmute representative
Aaron my my bad sorry I I I vote yes
thank you representative oy yes ber yes
ducet yes bin votes yes Elliot yes
janigian yes Nunes yes Baxter yes
spillsbury
yes
tutor
yes Aly yes Ames yes Southworth yes
Malloy yes representative shamberg
representative shamberg vote Yes Tucker
yes garlo yes Smith yes Lane yes hackin
Phillips
representative oh say yes for me one
more time yes thank you Murphy yes major
yes Mr Chair by vote of 24 to nothing
the most motion
carries the vote was 24 to nothing for o
to pass with $311 million estimate for
$341 million estimate for 22 and $360
million estimate for
23 I'll do the same for the real estate
transfer
tax on the real estate transfer
tax midpoint for the Republicans was
13.4 the Democrats was
[Music]
194 the midpoint for the Republicans on
fy22 was
182.5 the Democrats was 182
the midpoint for
the Republicans on FY 23 was 173
point2 and for the Democrats was
170 as you can see they're pretty
close so I would make a motion about to
pass for the revenues for Real Estate
transfer tax for fy21
one
is
as2
170 I'm sorry
171 just to repeat again
194 182 and 171 are the revenue
estimates is there is there a second to
that
motion second representative yes I
[Music]
second I don't know who but I I I I said
I would second it maybe somebody else
got their first
was there
somebody representative T second did as
well
who representative tutor Tor
okay I don't see any
problem
um any questions or comments on the real
estate for Revenue representative bramy
followed by representative Aly
me had her hand up first but I just
going to make uh the same thing I did
before uh 21 that's 2.1 above our
February estimate uh 22 1.7 million
above our February estimate and 23 2.2
above our February estimate so about $2
million a year above our February
estimate thank you um I think that uh
representative Lane has something to
offer she's been talking with Ben
Frost represent
Lane um thank you um I spoke to Ben
Frost who's um with New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority he said he was
surprised that dr's figures were going
down um given their forecast and what
they're seeing um and he also said that
the single um what you call the starter
Home Market has never really recovered
from the Great Recession and then
continues to be problematic and there
are no projects that he is aware of
large ones that they are working with
for single family homes it was just more
of an information that I was providing
um uh based on comments from
yesterday right and that's the sad fact
for New Hampshire there the home
construction isn't keep the the
man and the inventory
for uh
older homes is very
low any further discussion or comments
on the motion about to
pass nor my hands up uh represent
Bron yeah I just want to react to the
last statement I mean it appears I have
it on one sheet uh Dr dr's estimates or
transfer did go up a bit uh not down
from
February um I don't want to read all the
numbers but I can if you
want in each category for each year dr's
numbers went up a couple of
million uh each each year so what that's
worth
so thank you okay any further questions
or
comments
Sone represent call the vote
um represent Bernstein you're
muted thank you the motion is for the
real estate tax to be from 21 through 23
to be 194 million 182 million and 171
million respectively we'll begin the
roll call Vote with representative
abrami
yes
Aaron yes oy yes obber yes ducet yes
burin votes yes Elliot yes janigian yes
Nunes yes Baxter yes spilsbury yes
tutor yes
Aly yes
Ames uh yes
Southworth yes Malloy yes representative
shamberg representative shamberg votes
yes Tucker yes garlo yes Smith yes
Lane yes hackin Phillips yes Murphy yes
major yes Mr chair the motion carries 24
to
nothing the vote being 24 to nothing the
motion about to pass on the real
estate
transfer revenues for
21 at 194 million 22 182 million and 23
million now the um Republicans got
together and did a caucus on the indd
revenues and
the
representative elme had indicated take
the revenues as suggested by the agency
and just to let you know what the
numbers we came up with for the
IND it's hard to believe it but the um
Republican numbers was for 21 was
130.5 the February estimates was
1288 Republican estimate for
22 was 16
136.6 the February estimate was
1365 and the Republican
estimate
23 was
138.74503
have sens the difference on
fy21 like 1.7 million
fy22 210 of a million FY 23 710 of a
million I I would
take I would honor a motion to uh keep
the indd revenues
as estim made in
February do I hear a motion on that I
would so
move represent
moves the
IM revenues as made as estimated in
February seconded
by representative janigian
representative
Jan any questions or comments Mr chair
could you read the three numbers to me
beginning with
yes
28.8
136.6 wait a
minute
yeah
138 for 23 sorry about that I just had
to check cross check the numbers
here any
discuss my question is uh are you
talking about interest in dividends than
yes
okay
um
then the last one I think we need to
do okay are we ready for the roll call
vote Mr chair yeah I'm
I didn't write that who made the
motion I think I did did I I think I did
am
yeah Ames and
janigian
yes okay we if everyone's clear on the
the
question okay I I'll
repeat the motion and the motion made
repr aims is to
keep estimates on indd the
same in February and that is 128.3
million 21 136.6 million 22 138 million
23 okay we will begin the roll call Vote
with representative abami yes
Aaron yes
oy yes obber yes
ducet yes bin votes yes Elliot yes
janigian yes
Nunes yes Baxter yes sillsbury
yes
tutor yes Aly yes Ames
yes Southworth yes Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes yes
representative thank you representative
Tucker yes garlo yes
Smith representative
Smith representative Smith are you still
with
us
I don't see her she she just rejoined us
there she is yes I'm sorry yes I just
had a momentary problem okay no problem
uh I'm going to record your vote as yes
yes please I was here when the question
was called thank you representative Lane
yes hacken Phillips yes Murphy yes
chairman m
yes Mr chair the vote carries 24 to
nothing the vote being 24 to nothing the
indd taxes estimates stay the same as
made in
February now I want to do something a
little
different
Chris yes Russ and major um the
liquor
yeah let me
see so so liquer came in today and said
that um they could live with the 129
million in fiscal year 21 and suggested
if you wanted to go up in 22 could go up
to
138.3mm
feel should
they go with the Liquor Commission
should they use estimates from February
or should they do something
different uh represent Southwest I'd be
comfortable just going to 138 for for
the two
years so 138
for 22 and 138 for
23 yes and then uh staying at 129 for 21
yes you make that
motion
yes and seconded by I'll second that
representative Ronney any further
discussion on liquor
going to 129 for 21
138 for 22 and
138 for
23 uh Representative bronley no I had my
hand up before that's
okay any further discussion if not then
I'll ask the court to call the role
thank you Mr chair and uh Hey group
let's try and set a record a speed
record on this one you guys ready we'll
begin the roll call Vote with
representative abrami yes Aaron yes orry
yes obber yes
ducet yes burin votes yes Elliot yes
janigian yes Nunez yes Baxter yes
dillsbury yes tutor yes Aly yes Ames yes
Southworth yes
yes representative shamberg
representative shamberg votes yes Tucker
yes go Marlo yes Smith yes Lane yes
hackin Phillips yes Murphy yes major yes
I've just been advised we have set a new
world record Mr chair the motion passes
24 to
nothing the vote been 24 to nothing
nothing for the revenues for the liquor
for 21 22 and
23 at 129 138 and 138 respectively
passes now Chris did we have any other
changes that we made
prior to any of these revenues I don't
see any the insurance provided some
ranges today that were higher than what
you had um pre viously
estimated but left it to you to decide
whether you wanted to do anything with
that so for fiscal year 21 um they could
see somewhere between a 128. two and 131
million for fiscal year
22 um they could see somewhere between
127 and 130
million and then for fiscal year 23 they
had
133.33
million
to to 135 even or 135 I had 135 even
okay all right committee what do you
want to do representative
browny yeah um I asked them if they
could live with the midpoint on the uh
on 22 and
23 uh they felt comfortable with the
midpoint that would be
128.57
and uh
134 I'm rounding
three uh and they also said for the
21 they could go up as high as 131 but
maybe we don't need to do that maybe you
know maybe 130 or something like that so
I I I would suggest we look at maybe
130 uh if you want to be conservative we
can go to
128 and maybe
134 so you're making a motion for that
representative rney well let's I think
there's going to be more discussion than
I'll make that motion
but representative bramy made a motion
to going to 130 128 and 134 respectively
for years 21 22 and
23 seconded by I second then
represent
discussion representative El me oh I was
just going to comment that on the
insurance people are pretty conservative
in their estimates and that they think
that they're going to go to 131 this
year but we can do the ones that we've
got okay any further discussion on the
revenue I don't represent hack Phillips
Mr chair I just wanted to clarify did
representative abrami state for fiscal
year 22 that it was 12850 or 128
128 round it down 130 for 21 128 for 22
and 134 for
23 any further
discussions or questions on the
amendment s none ask the call thank you
Mr chair we'll begin the roll call Vote
with representative abrami yes Aaron yes
ory
yes over yes duet yes the clerk votes
yes Elliot yes janigian yes
Nunes yes I'm sorry no problem
representative Baxter yes spillsbury yes
tutor yes Aly yes Ames yes Southward yes
Malloy yes representative Thomas
shamberg Mr C representative shamberg
votes yes thank you sir Tucker yes
garlo yes Smith yes Lane yes hackin
Phillips yes Murphy yes major
yes at the risk of being accused of
group think the committee votes 24 to
nothing for the
motion vote been 24 to nothing for
the
insurance estimates for years 22 23 and
24 are 130 million 128 million 134
million
passes
now
since have had no
changes from either Republicans Or
democrats on the tobacco
tax the insurance
tax no ation
tax just change the insurance tax
Norm what's that we just changed the
insurance I'm sorry yes okay let me let
me I'm GNA just Page by Page the first
page of the handout is since there's
been no recommended changes in the
tobacco
text and the communication TX
do I hear a motion where we accept the
estimates from
February for 21 22 and
23 I
move one big motion Norm as we go and
just accumulate these and do one big
motion on
them I'm going to so so the first one is
communication
tax
go so we're doing
the tobacco and communication it's been
motioned to made
by southw by representative Aly was that
it I agreed but I'd really like to put
the other ones on too
but okay um need a republic
no no representative major I think what
representative Aly is suggesting is that
we keep on adding the other taxes to
this so we can have one big vote okay
will
youw your
motion yes I withdraw my motion okay so
we'll
add
P court fines and
fees security
beer tax um Mr Mr chair can we talk
about the beer tax real
quick Mr chair okay what I want to do
the ones discuss
anymore
so
okay and C the docket of
that
so
let me
go let me go
back we won't have any motions until we
thr
talking about the
various
Revenue I'll go through them one at a
time on tobacco tax anybody have any
questions or comments on the tobacco
tax I'm sorry but what numbers are we
looking at I just want to make sure I've
got the right sheet in front of me you
will have
it put the sheet up which shows
the what's it look I can't worksheet
okay thank
you March 16th
yeah the March 16th
worksheet I sent you a simplified
version of that that's marked February
23rd but that included
the
later we're going to work on the March
16th
worksheet thank you let me start the
process
again
the F the first one that we haven't
discussed is the tobacco tax any
questions on the tobacco
tax represent Brown you have your hands
up no it's going to be for the beer tax
I'll put my hand
down all right I don't see anything on
the tobacco
tax the insurance I'm sorry the
tax any questions on
the on the court fines and
fees
Securities now the beer
tax yes even though even though uh the
uh Department of uh Liquor Commission um
has on their sheet 13.1 part the
discussion I I don't I don't think it's
worth changing R three R
13.2 so I I would agree to keep it at
the 13 I would suggest that we just keep
it at the
13.2 anybody else yeah I I suggest we
keep it at Sam
Adams I think it's more the craft
be okay any any other discussion on the
bear tax
the the category
others
category tobacco
settlement you skipped
Lottery oh we haven't done
loty I think he didn't offer anything he
didn't offer a change oh pretty
optimistic but he he didn't want to uh
change
yet um how about Lottery discussion on
lottery tobacco
settlement Mr chairman yes he is
30% about $36 million over plan at this
point and he doesn't really see any
change I would think we could at least
for this year not the rest put another
20 million into that
estimate so
Lottery come back the lottery itself
okay I mean tobacco settlement
jeez so we'll come back to the category
tobacco
settlement utility property tax
Statewide property
tax
Medicaid now if I've done this
right just bear with
me
I would entertain
motion that we keep the estimated
revenues the same as what we provided in
hr1 for the category tobacco
communication
tax court fines and
fees security
revenues
Feer category
others
Lottery we're going to discuss lottery I
think
Norm I Norm I think we decided to keep
that one out because we wanted to
discuss it we decided to keep tobacco
settlement
no no it was lot it was
Lottery lottery is the one we want to
talk
about thank
you then
tobacco
utility
Statewide in the Medicaid
recoveries so one two three so I'll go
through that in the reverse recovery
Statewide property tax utility property
tax tobacco settlement other
beer
security P
fine communication tax and
tobacco do I have a mo I'll make that
motion motion's been made second
seconded by representative elmy
to revenue estimates February to be a
future Revenue
estimates the Motions been made and
seconded do we have any further
discussion then I'm going to have
representative
Bernstein call the vote on that thank
you Mr chair if the question is clear to
everyone and I think it is we'll begin
the roll call Vote with representative
abramy yes
Aaron yes
oy
yes obber yes duet yes the clerk votes
yes ell yes janigian yes Nunes yes
Baxter yes
billsburg yes
Tudor yes Aly
yes Ames yes Southworth yes Malloy yes
representative Thomas
shamberg yes Mr cour Tucker yes go
Marlo uh yes sorry Smith yes he wasn't
live
Lane
yes hackin Phillips
yes Murphy yes chairman major yes Mr
chair the vote carries 24 to nothing
with the vote being 24 to nothing to
accept the revenue estimates from
February on
Tobacco communication
tax court fines and fees SEC here
others tobacco
settlement util property tax Statewide
property tax and Medicaid recoveries
passes by a vote of 24 to
Z now we
need to go
to
Lottery
lottery and
representative El
me thank you Mr chairman um what Charlie
told us was that he is 30% above plan at
this point and the plan was
110 on million so that is is about
33 uh million dollar above plan and um
that he doesn't really see any change
coming but he likes to be conservative
ative and so he's he wants to keep the
110 I would suggest that we could we
could take 20 million of that and stick
it into 21 and it would not affect
obviously 22 or 23 because on it is
random on what happens in
Lottery okay um you're making that into
a
motion I am what why do you think this
is good
because on he says that he he is now 30%
above plan we only have uh we have four
months left actually because uh next
month we will get March and then we will
get April and then we will get May and
June together in June so on uh there's
four months still to go but but he says
that he is seeing growth in everything
not just in the ones affected by the
people who have come from Massachusetts
to stay in their second homes in the
Lake
Region though that is part of the growth
on and there have been two major
jackpots equal to $10
million in
uh January that on we have booked which
is anonymous it do get considered in his
Revenue estimates um but and he
does like to be very safe about things
but on I do think that we could book at
least uh another 20 million onto the the
plan number which would take us up to
discussion
on what represent Al
suggested yeah um Chris do you have H
can I ask Chris a question Mr chair do
you do you have the revenue Focus
handy or does anybody have the revenue
Focus handy for uh for February hold on
just one second and I'll get it up for
you
I'm not I'm I'm I'm probably not going
to disagree with you represent me I just
want to see where we were in
February okay share your screen
Chris so you should be seeing it on the
screen
now can you go to the uh the last
page date yep all right so
Lottery can you expand it a little bit
yep so we are yeah wow you a date we 34%
ahead right we're 21 million ahead yeah
all
right
I I I didn't feel yeah but remember that
was only because of the trillion dollar
payout 10 was 10 million yeah billion
dollars extra on top of
things and I'm ask actually asking for
the 10 million to be
booked represent is only adding 10
million on top of our last
estimate our last estimate was uh
12.6 I think the motion is to go to
13.6 is that correct yes it
is I don't think that's too risky to do
given given what what he said and what
these numbers are
showing that's just my that's my
input you were kind of weake I didn't
get to your last
statement I'm saying given given
uh uh Charlie McIntyre's testimony and
looking at these
numbers I would concur with
representative aly's
motion all right and that would be to go
13.6
million
yes uh are you seconding that motion
I'll second it okay so
it would only apply to
fy21 yes
right so the motion
is the estimate for revenue for
fy21 would be
13.6 million for for the lottery it was
made by representative BR uh Aly second
by representative
Bron any further discussion no
comments yeah I support this is
representative Ames yes um well I I
support the motion but I wonder if it
shouldn't be expanded to include the
next two years so we get this Lottery
done um
suggest yeah Mo represent Aly to
13.6 for
fy22 and then uh
25 Z for
fy2 the other one is FY 21 and
125 for fy22 and
1275 for FY
right represent want are you all with
that I I will accept that Amendment
thank I second that change okay so the
motion on the
floor is 13.6 million for
fy21 125 million for
fy22
127.5 million for FY
23 any further discussion and
representative Hackman Phillips I just
received a message from representative
Murphy that there's been a
Transformer uh that's been destroyed in
Hover which has disrupted power and
internet in downtown hover um he said
that he does not anticipate be able to
sign back in for the vote so he
apologized for that
mistake thank
you that could happen to almost any
happen to all of us here so maybe we
ought to take since there's no
discussion we ought to move on before
our trans Transformers blow
up
I think it's
better are we ready for the roll call Mr
chair yes all right we will begin the
roll call on the motion with
representative abrami yes representative
Aon yes
oy yes obber yes duet yes first votes
yes Elliot yes janigian yes nunz yes
Baxter yes spillsbury
yes tutor yes Aly yes Ames yes South yes
Malloy yes representative Thomas
shamberg representative shamberg votes
yes thank you representative Tucker yes
garlo yes Smith
yes yes representative hackin Phillips
yes representative Murphy is not voting
representative chair major yes Mr chair
the vote carries 23 to
nothing with a vote 23 to nothing
estimates Mr
chair representative shamberg
here would would the the court just
please note that representative
Murphy um was unable to vote because
of the Transformer situation dly noted
thank you
sir then the vote 23 to nothing on the
lottery revenues of 13.6 for
fy21 125 for
fy22 and 127.5 for FY 23 pass it
now CH can you bring your spreadsheet up
and tell us and show us the the
totals so you should be seeing the
screen
now and hopefully you can see the last
row in the Bold is
the um the total for the new estimates
and then just below that is difference
from your prior estimate so in fiscal
year 21 you went from 2.67 4.5 to 2725
point4 an increase of 50.9
million in fiscal year 22 you went from
25.7 to
27640 an increase of 38.3
million and then in fiscal 23 you went
from
2.8.5 an increase of 45.1
million and over the three years it's a
total increase of
million I think finance committee will
be dancing
but.
and rep major if I if it's okay um the
conclusion of your meeting I'll send
this spreadsheet out to all the
members with a 318 date on it um so that
you know that it was done today and I'll
leave the end column as you see it thank
you I would that we have one more thing
to
do and uh and that is to look at the and
revenues due to legis changes so could
you bring up that change sheet
press um which one that show the house
built
too your your sheet from the other day
okay yeah so I'm gonna stop
sharing Mr chair could I could I just
remind all the members to hit mute we're
getting some interference which is
making it hard to hear so if you're not
speaking please hit
mute thank
you so you should see on the screen now
the sheet from yesterday the only thing
that's different is um you had asked me
to add the out years on the
indd
yeah that would be basically um a static
loss I guess if that's the right term
but
on the idea that you would have been at
say 120 million to start with and you
went down by six and then it would be
six plus whatever the next year for 24
to get the
28.5 just it's just so you understand
that that's what that is so at the end
you're gonna have zero dollars of so 116
16.9 was the amount that was used
because for the ones that are joining us
right now we collect 11
16.9 in the indd tax and facing it out
of five years this is the numbers you
would get so what I want to do is go
line by
line
um line two which is the additional Dr
Auditors we talked the dras and that's
still a good number it would bring in
extra
$700,000 for
fy22 and $3.2 million in FY
23 any questions or comments on that if
not the meals and room rate
decrease from 9% to 8 and a
half% you will see part of that decrease
in
fy22 it reduce the revenues by $1.4
million and by $19 million in
fi23 and then it will continue on
just just a comment on that one um I
think Dr did it uh did that calculation
and they did it on the basis
of oh revenues a couple years ago can't
remember um and uh now that we've got
got actual estimated
revenues um they should be done off of
the estimate but as it turns out the
estimate is about the same as that
previous
and it's so I I'm accepting this number
I just thought I'd throw that
explanation in any further moments or
questions on this on these numbers for
the
bet I mean the mes and room
reduction okay the next combines two
changes um changing the thre to 2ou
$250,000 and the
gross Enterprise Value to
$250,000 we won't have any effect
fy22 but a reduced Revenue by $3.1
million in
23 any comments
questions the next is the Mr Mr chairman
I I just wanted Assurance I I think that
the loss of 3.1 continues into the
future it doesn't grow
correct the only way it grows is if
there's more businesses that fall into
that
range more more
business it would be I would think it'd
be
trivial the BET rate decrease from
0.6% to 0.55
5% you'll see part of that as they're
implementing it fy22 will reduce
revenues by 4.7 million and 13.3 million
in FY
23 Mr chairman I think that one does
grow over the
years that will grow as the reeven as
the businesses grow
but also as on we catch up with the
three years
prior yes yes there's the
over yeah if I could make a suggestion I
I'd like to see these these
columns going forward from 23 for this
one where it is significant amount of
money populated um so that we can see
the impact in the year years beyond the
two-year period of the budget I said
that yesterday is
m still
there Melissa or
carollyn Y I'm here representative major
okay do you have the numbers on the rate
decrease
.55% going out to
2425 yep so the the final impact will be
felt in fiscal year 24 and um it would
be 3.2 million a
reduction so minus 4.7 and
22 minus
13.3
23 and you're saying in 24 how much
three uh minus 3.2 million minus 3.2
million is that cumulative
that is a year-over-year
impact the cumulative total is
21.2 at the end of fiscal
24 I think that's the cumulative that
we're showing for the indd
[Music]
and isn't that what we want to
show that's what that's correct ripson
Ames on the indd you did show the
cumulative that's what reps and major
had started and that's what I continued
on it
so
cumulative
on rate
decrease also if we could get the total
between the rate decrease and the
offsetting
BPT so if I can ask the committee a
question I'm not sure what screen what
you're seeing on my screen right
now are
you we're seeing
the I don't know uh what document it is
but it's a spreadsheet it's
representative
Majors okay so it might be helpful if I
switch into the Dr document that has the
information I think you're asking for so
justop and reshare that
oh all right so now you're seeing a a
Blue Block
screen I hope so it says fiscal impact
0.55% bet rate
change is that what you're seeing on my
on your screen now from from my share
yes okay so the so here is the in the
Box 22 they assume a base of 254 million
you're going to lose 4.6 million that
brings you down to
249 if you want to be make it cumulative
in the next year it's a if you're going
off the base you've already decreased it
by the four million um the 4.6 million
plus the 13.3 to get you to 236 right
here but if you want to know if you're
were going from the 254 you'd be losing
18 million so there's a couple of ways
it's been
shown um when we would carry something
like this on the Surplus statement we
would do it kind of as a static analysis
and we would say okay it's based on the
254 we would take 4.6 um and then the
18 and then you had asked uh for the BPT
piece and it's just below
that so the year year yearly component
is the 46 133 and the
31 and the cumulative is 4 6 18 and 21
corre correct
yeah and then for the BPT below you you
have a positive of
2.8 8.1 and then 1
.9 in the three years and cumulative of
12.9 overall three
years right they go
together yes yep total loss at the at
yearly at the end of
8.2
yep and obviously I mean this is dr's
sheet so if I'm Miss
um representing something I hope Melissa
or Devon or somebody will chime in
but doing it perfectly
Chris I like the vote of confidence so
if I think you have one more showing the
two of them
together yeah I got got talking and
didn't scroll yes so that's the 8.2 that
represent Wy just mentioned on the
bottom corner here
okay
um now can we go back to the other sheet
yep are you all set represent
names I yes I I I I hope that on the
spreadsheet that we're about to see
we'll then populate the
U the the additional years going out U
with accumulative numbers as we did
indd so can
we get those numbers
there yep
um for the rate
decrease and it also have to do it for
the
offsetting vpt revenue
increase that's true have to have
both understood I'm just I'm having
trouble finding the document now that
I've switched out of
it give me a moment take your
time I would I would say that uh this is
important to have as backup information
information that we can all take away
but you know the Focus right now is on
the fy22 and FY 23 numbers yes a task at
hand so this doesn't need to delay us so
can can we proceed
and then uh we'll get that information
exactly and sent
out is that okay represent yes okay
yes I think we all need to see that
information that's why I extended some
of them
um the next line you offsetting BPT
Revenue increases when you
have due to the rate decrease you have
less
bet and then you're using less bet as
credit against the
BPT and that would when you did
that the BPT Revenue decrease now if you
have less credit against the
BPT then the business tax revenues
increases so the offsetting shows that
when you have 4.7
milon offset it increases the BPT
Revenue by 2.8 because not all
dollars uh
generated by the
BET are offsetting BPT because there's a
number of businesses that pay bet but
don't have any BPT so that's why those
numbers aren't the same in the second
year the minus
.3 million reduction in the BET affects
the BPT by 8.1 million
increase so I have confidence that uh Dr
has has done this they they know the
inside story so I think
it this all makes sense to me the next
is the indd tax reduction over fiveyear
phase out it doesn't affect the first
first year but it starts in the second
year and this is the cumulative effect
each
year but for our purposes it affects FY
23 and
FY FY
23 L is
ready
um the next is the single sales Factor
delay
that puts restores back the $20 million
that we put out when we had to use Cur
current law this puts that $20 million
back because we're pushing that
implementation implementation out a few
years the next is the historic
racing uh that's House Bill 62
6 they plan on putting that into
hb2 that goes through it will increase
revenues by $6.4 million fy22 and 12
million FY 23 nor Norm representative
Bron yeah I think uh I think part of
conversation with Charlie he he's now
saying six million and 12 million six
million instead of 12 okay 6 million
instead of the 6 4 and then 12 million
the next
year that 6.4 to
6.0 so um just rep major I'm sorry just
so the committee understands um in the
fiscal note worksheet that the
department provided us they had 6.4 and
12.9 so when you see a fiscal note come
out on this bill um it will have the 6.4
and 12.9 and it should also show
expenditures of about 6 100,000 um each
year associated with implementing this
but I only say that because the finance
committee may take the information they
got in the revised fiscal note that was
requested and use the 6.4 and the 12.9
when they do their Surplus statement but
I'll I'll let them know that the
committee has um after conversations
with um director McIntyre indicated six
and 12 would be a better Revenue number
okay yeah can I speak that
representative bronley again that point
n is is the the the money that that's
directed towards the uh problem gambling
fund um and somehow it got originally
got put in here as 12.9 but it really is
12 in in their fiscal note they talk
about the about the that money and when
I look at the fiscal note the math works
I mean it's it's 12 million
to uh the education trust fund and
change and then there's about 800 800
between 800 900 in the uh going to the
the fund for the uh problem
gambling I just want
to
say represent
Ames um yeah um the uh I feel I I I need
to comment because I engaged in a
exchange with director McIntyre on this
and I just want to say that I his
explanation was sufficient for me and uh
so I think uh these are good numbers if
we're going forward with this
uh this initiative um of course I've got
a different perspective on whether we
should go forward with it but that's not
what we're talking about
here Mr chairman represent
thank you uh I was confused about what
he was saying it sounded like uh the
current problem G gaming Council
whatever it's called has only a couple
of tens of thousands of dollars coming
into it and hasn't spent any of it so it
lapses is that true
I I don't know the answer to
that all I know is his estimates of what
has been it will raise a 6 million and
million and as far as the distribution
of those that fund
that's this is Mr chair so I have the
fiscal note right in front of me there's
a line that says estimated
breakage which is 15% a handle to be
used for problem gambling services and
they have the figure of 821 point2 uh
,250 each of the
years so but then we decided to PR rate
that because
of uh it would that would be prated but
again it's it's it's what's in going to
the what's you know some of this may
wind up in the general fund May wind up
in education trust fund I guess we just
don't
know uh but it's but in in the fiscal
note it's all pointed to the uh problem
gambling
services
so so but this is a conservative I guess
you could cons you could say the 12
million is a conservative number
and yes representative Aly some of it
may I I don't know it must lapse but I I
I don't know how that fund
works yeah it would be nice to try to
find out if we're going to be expanding
addiction of gambling all over the state
thank
you the
um any further discussion on historic
Horse
Rising
and then on line 11 I I'm going to skip
the carry forward but on line 11 you
have House Bill 591 that uh representa
obber wanted me to put in there uh the
liquor license fees and that generates
$35 A5 million doar each year positive
can I can I speak to that Norm yes yeah
this this is the bill that we worked on
last year uh that got didn't make it
through it corrects the the the $6
problem there are 174 businesses that
are only paying $6 for a tobacco
license uh but in reality and I can't
remember the exact number uh the our
bill increased it I refiled the bill
this year it went to Edna they approved
it then it went to finance it went to
finance because originally we had had
two positions in there if you
recall uh but Edna actually took the two
positions out so technically it didn't
really need to go to
finance I I was in communication when we
we said representative Alber were're
talking about Lyn Alber not not
Russ uh when I talked to Lynn about this
because she had uh had uh retained all
of the bills that came to her division
uh second committee bills and I reached
out to her and I said well I don't know
if you really want to retain this one uh
there's really no work here it's we're
increasing the fees to where they should
be and it's going to generate about
$336,000 uh and I I guess she heard me
because
now uh she's uh wanted to see that back
in here so so that's the the long
version of the story I
guess but that that increase of for
those 174 businesses will equate to
about 30 6 million
36 million not million 36
3,000,000 thank
you right each year each
year
um here's here's what I does anybody
have any questions on what we've
discussed thus far except for the
business profits carry
forward what I would like to do is is
get an acceptance
on all of that except for the line
10 and then that's a whole discussion
that I'd like to carry on
after we we each have a memo that just
came out today and with various options
on how to address this and I would like
the
Dr looks like
that so
I'd like to have a motion on all these
other items except
for the item 10 and then come back from
lunch and then we can uh discuss the
credit Carry It Forward I'll make the
motion that we accept the uh this report
as is except for uh uh row
10 and represent Aly do you second that
you muted represent Al
me um that means I'm seconding six HP
626 I'd like to decline oh okay that's
right represent of major represent
shamberg second
626 you're seconding the the rest of the
items on that
spreadsheet yes the mo that
representative bromy made okay motion
been made by representative Bry second
by representative shanberg to accept the
items on that change in Revenue due to
legislative changes spreadsheet except
for line 10 which has to
do business credit carrying forward item
any further discussion represent yes
I've got a I've got a comment a question
I'm sorry comment I guess represent
and Then followed by
representes
okay I'm sorry was that were you
call you had your hand raised yes I do I
cannot vote on HB 626 um so if it's
included in this or when we get to it uh
have a conflict of interest because of
uh my Law Firm represents in that
industry
okay can I make a a my my comment is
related
to what was just said
um and it is that my understanding of
this
motion is that it re relates solely to
the Cal
calculation of Revenue impact of these
various Provisions that are in house
build two and if house build two passes
with them this is what the impact will
be exactly and that it it does not in
any way carry with it a suggestion by
any one of us that we
endorse the substance of the particular
proposal is that correct yes yes so for
example Hospital 626 has been mentioned
but I'll mention a different one the
phase out of the IND
TX I'm
quite ready to vote on that one and on
626 on the revenue
impact and in doing so I'm not conveying
my
position one way or the other on those
or any of the
others Mr chair maybe we just change the
language of the
motion to reflect
that
to accept the revenue
impact of the
items on that
spreadsheet right I just want to make
sure representative Ames is
satisfied I don't know if you have other
words that you think would be more
reflective of that we're just voting on
the revenues and not the substance of I
think the way yes I think the way the
chair just uh referenced it is is just
fine with backed up by this
discussion so the motion is to accept
the revenue
estimates on the spreadsheet except
for that dealing with the business
profits tax credit carry
forward and just the revenue
estimates point of order yes
representative sou um can't
representative Lane vote on beh half of
her
constituents again only on the numbers
she's not voting on any of the
bills right if she's here she's gonna
have to
vote one way or the
other representa lane did you understand
what
represent I don't I guess I need to be
educated I was planning to
abstain
Jordan yes I think she's correct uh she
has an option as a a member to declare
conflict of interest and vote or declare
a conflict of interest and not vote it's
her
choice uh on the floor the same thing
would apply here she's declaring a
conflict of interest and and not voting
which is what Paul's told us that the
house rules now are applying to the
committee rules so if you take what the
house rules are and apply it to the
committee representative Lane has an
option of not voting by abstaining with
a conflict of interest on
file and as an attorney or or working
for a law firm I think she's correct
Okay I accept that
so are we
represent had your hand up you lowered
it
okay so if you vote represent Aaron has
her hand up
represent yes thank you Mr chair as I
understand uh from attending other
committees um in the case of someone not
being able to vote due to a conflict
interest they simply leave the room
because if you are in the room when
there is a vote uh taking place you
either have to vote Yes or no um there
is no exstension that I am aware
of that is
correct leave the
room no no but the difference was Paul
said that what we had been doing in the
past no longer applies because we're now
doing
what we do on the house floor we're
doing in
committee yes and then on the house
floor you cannot leave the room when
there's a vote you have to either vote
Yes or no so in the case of where you
would abstain or not wish to vote you
would have to leave the room that's no
that's incorrect you're noticing
yourself as a as having a conflict of
interest
and that's that's what the the point is
that's what representative Lane is doing
she's trying to do the right thing no I
understand that and I applaud her and I
thank her for
that
okay why don't I take the prerogative
here and saying that if you don't want
to something in there that you don't
want to support then just leave the
room or perhaps just turn off her video
yes turn our camera off for a few
minutes goodbye
hey it
enough okay um all right any further
discussion on the motion just one
clarification on the motion Mr chair
right now I have it down accept the
revenue estimat on the report can you
name the report for
me it's it's titled change in Revenue
due to legislative
changes thank
you now can we find something else
esoteric to extend this a little bit
longer can we we set to take the
vote okay let's begin the roll call vote
uh for the motion that is on the table
I'm sure it's clear with everyone we'll
begin the roll call Vote with
representative abami yes
Aaron yes
o yes obber yes
juet yes burin votes yes Elliot yes
janigian yes Nunes yes Baxter yes
spillsbury
yes
tutor yes
Aly yes Ames yes Southworth yes
Malloy yes representative shamberg
representative shamberg votes yes Tucker
yes
garlo yes Smith yes I don't see her I
don't see her either I'm still gonna
note conflict of interest not voting if
that's all right representative hacken
Phillips yes representative Murphy is
unable to vote due to a power outage
chairman major yes chair Mr chair the
vote is 22 in favor faor with two
members not
voting the vote being 22 to
zero the motion to accept the revenue
estimates outline spreadsheet changes in
Revenue due to legislative changes
except for line 10
which does has to do with business
profits tax credit carry forward item
passes so now we will take a break and
come back in 30 minutes
okay perfect we'll come back in 30
minutes and tle tackle the credit carry
over issue saying 120 it's
120 120 okay thank you for the
break mute yourselves please
representative burin representative over
here yes sir can you tell me if you saw
representative Smith on either of those
last three votings all I saw was her
picture uh no I I I was looking at a
different monitor so I can't say whether
her video was on or off I'm I'm a little
concerned about that I know we have to
see live pictures to voting yeah with uh
the votes that aren't very controversial
I'm not a real stickler on it but any
close votes I'd appreciate if you could
speak up if the video is not on and give
me another set of eyes so to speak I'm a
quiet person I said I don't see her but
it's
overwhelmed just a comment no I did I
did see her uh when she was Voting so I
I don't recall her not being on vot on
video when she was Voting what you saw
was her picture no no no I did see her
voting so she must have been really
quick about turning it on and off
yeah a lot of people do that bir Jean
these are really different kinds of
votes um in a way uh we would have
normally just raised our hands if we had
been uh in conquered so it's not really
quite the
same iats didn't crush
your say that again
Tom I said to Russ I said one of those
cats didn't cross in front of his screen
at the time did
it he has six of them so the odds are
pretty good one of them
was watch your
mouth
for
where's the
dog dog wants
water
that half hour goes by
fast it
does just an update it sounds like
representative Murphy saw a truck in
front of his home so like a power truck
so sounds like they're they should have
power again
shortly oh good
good couldn't you vote with with h your
cell phone and
FaceTime
yes it seems to me we ought to have that
as a fallback
position it's too bad to put in all the
time and not get not
devoted and I do think it's impressive
when we have a
unanimity he might I mean he could use
zoom on his phone he wouldn't even have
to call in and use
FaceTime I'm not sure he has the app
downloaded but I could I'll recommend
that to him okay I think it'd be nice to
have a fallback of some sort
Janine can you let Carolyn leer and
Melissa Rollins in
yep is Karen rounds part of no no she's
someone else
right I don't
know she HHS
yes she's
HHS do we need
HHS I'm just interested in what we're
[Music]
doing and Adam kpo I don't know who he
is no he's been there all day
though
Chris do you have
a the document
V yeah I can put that up
good representative
Ames Mrs Jenny can you hear me yeah um
it's it's your feedback that everyone is
hearing and I don't know what to do to
fix it but it seems like maybe when you
sit back it's better better than when
you're
close I I don't know
but if Norms trying to talk while yours
is squelching it's hard to hear him so
that's why I I mute you but you do talk
a lot so I try not
to yeah I don't hear the feedback at
this end so I don't realize it but I
appreciate the feedback from you and um
I think maybe maybe I can turn down the
volume that might help I don't I don't
really have
any yeah that might do it thank
you your names are real
techy I don't think
so and this year I'm perfectly in the
the average age of the the House of
Representatives I'll be 61 in two months
so I'm in the
middle far as I'm concerned
I got kids your
age is that the mean the median or the
mode uh Paul Smith said it was the
average so I don't know I it's probably
not the mean I wouldn't think we need
some more Tim boers in
here in a lot of
ways
yeah we got to figure out how to pay for
him
because at 18 or 19 or whatever he is
you
can't live with your parents
forever as in Tom
lockerman he's got I think two kids of
his own now
right and Willis left our committee
because he didn't have the time for it
with his job that paid him so that was
sad I thought it was sad Willis is a
good guy I
like I was going to U get a picture of
my latest or my newest and only great
great
granddaughter but uh oh great and have
it ready for
today it hasn't come
yet
oh my great great granddaughter is uh is
Bor the
ninth
so 7 pound 14 ounces 21 inches long you
got
it CU guess who else had those
statistics that's how I remember it
that's what I
was they named her Jenny though
but Aubrey right yep Aubrey yeah I like
that Aubrey
Mary all right uh I think we should
probably get
started
Melissa Melissa with
us I
am good um can you update us on this new
document that you put together at our
request to be able to spread out the
uh the
damage I shouldn't say damage spread out
the the effect
of reducing a credit
carry forward number that has grown to
more than a quarter of a billion
dollars and I looked at the memo
and looks like and I'll let you explain
it sure page3 it looks like you spread
it
out doesn't hit you very much in any one
particular
year as compared to if we went right to
the
50% yes if you could work walk us
through through this appreciate
it sure so this is the memo that I went
over yesterday and after we went over
the memo yesterday there were some
additional requests to see if we could
spread this out so it was less of an
impact in one particular in one
particular year we um in the limited
time we had we did try to run different
scenarios and the one that we found
limited the most is the third option
that you uh were just referencing
representative major would you like me
to cover the the the um three options I
went over yesterday or do you just want
me to cover the additional option today
I don't cover all three
options
sure because we do have some new people
here
perfect so the first option on page one
Chris if you can I think it's Chris's
screen if you can scroll up perfectly
yeah y just yell to me what you need me
to where you need me to be Melissa great
thank you um so what this this chart
here is is what is in hb2 which is
essentially limiting a credit carryover
by 50% of the the tax 50% of taxpayers
tax year liability this data is based on
tax year
2018 for the new members that are here
today I'll just quickly explain to you
what a credit carryover is so this can
can sort of make sense to you um what a
credit carryover is is when a
taxpayer has a tax liability on file
they pay that tax liability and
essentially they end up paying too much
money so if you overpay your liability
it becomes an overpayment and then you
have two options for those funds one you
can take them as a refund or two you can
ask those funds to be carried forward to
the next year I just want to caveat that
with although it says credit this does
not mean any of our previous credits
that we've talked about bet credits Coos
accounting credits that's different this
is excess cash that was paid against a
liability and is now requested to be
carried forward to the next tax year to
offset future
liabilities so in
hb2 there's a request to limit this cap
for taxure 2018 there's about $
279.50 per of the taxpayers tax
liability
so if we use tax year 2018 data you can
look at the different ranges below I'll
note that there's different ranges
because we don't know exactly when are
the taxpayer will request These funds
there's a couple of options they can
either adjust their estimate
payments and not make those estimate
payments and use their credit on file to
supplement those estimate payments and
then get a refund on the return or they
could could continue their normal
behavior make estimate
payments and then request the total
50% once the return is filed so because
we haven't this hasn't been in law this
is a A New Concept we put ranges to make
sure we sort of captured where the
taxpayer may make adjustments to their
returns so in 22 you can see if they
don't adjust any of their estimates
um there would be no impact but if they
do make adjustments to their estimates
there could be potentially 30.2 million
impact and then this carries on in 23 24
and 25 what I do want to know on this is
the total difference at the end has to
equal 137.5 million because that would
be the total reduction of
50% of the um using 50% of the cap so
whether where you picking the range the
bottom number does have to Total to
137.0 so that was our starting point
that's what's in our fiscal note for hb2
we then created additional scenarios
based on this impact being so large as
you can see in 2024 that7 Million number
is is pretty
big let me interrupt there the reason
why we asked for different
scenarios in year
2023 it could have an imp of $86
million or in year 24 impact of $17
million from either 20 million or
107 and that's would be disastrous for
us so so is there some way of fixing
this that it doesn't shake things up as
as much go ahead sure so Chris if you
just want to SC scroll down not all the
way just to get those alternative
options perfect um so next we talked
about different options and what we did
share with the committee um the other
day was that or yesterday was that some
taxpayers have in excess of 100% of
their liability on file um so we gave
you just some stats on here for quick
reference I won't go through them but
just know that they are in your memo and
they give you
100 200% above their tax liability in
credit carryovers 250 and then 500% and
then we you later used those numbers um
further down but just so you have those
numbers in front of
you if you can scroll down
Chris I do see Hands raised so I'm not
sure if you want me to take those
questions now before I go to the next
option representative Aaron you have a
question yes thank you Mr chair uh and
thank you Miss Rollins uh I'm interested
to know for money that uh is is held by
Dr so to speak uh for this
overpayment is is there any interest
that's tacked on to that do they acrew
any interest for the money that you have
that's that's their
over
payment so they do not in the reason is
is this
overpayment um I should have stated this
before too this overpayment we don't
know if it's getting used regularly um
we think it is so essentially they keep
it on file they use it to supplement
some of their tax and then they renew it
each time so it's not essentially old
money on file it gets refreshed every
single year so it is not earning
interest okay thank you welcome
represent
Ames
yeah thank you um I don't this may not
be the right time for this I um it's and
I'm perfectly fine with waiting until
Melissa Rollins completes her
explanation but I I I do want to put
forward it uh an appropriate time and
alternative to trying to create a a a
formula um similar to what's in front of
us um and the alternative would be
to uh to propose an amendment to House
Bill 2 that would establish a committee
or a commission to review um and make
recommendations after public hearings um
on this issue um and I can I can speak
and explain more about that but uh
that's why I had my hand up yeah why
don't you do that after she she gets
through this this disc discussion
fine all right great so this option we
did talk about yesterday this is another
option and this is where we cap those
Credit carryovers in hb2 remember it was
50% in this option we sort of do a phase
in approach where we cap it at 200% of
the tax liability for tax year 22 and
then we progressively go down 100% and
23 of the liability 75% of the liability
in 24 and then the 50% that's in hb2 in
tax year 25 so this approach is phased
in and you can see now in this one if
you look at the max numbers throughout
the year uh fiscal year 24 instead of
being 107 million in the previous
analysis that I just gave it's 45
million in this analysis still big
numbers but it is a a smaller approach
and your end bottom line is still 100
37.3 because it still ends at that 50%
cap on the
ccos if there are no questions I'll go
to the next option we spoke about
yesterday so this option like the prior
option starts at 200% but this one would
end the cap at 100% of the taxpayers tax
liability where hb2 ends it at
50% this one has similar impacts of the
last analysis that we just showed
you sen of
Comm great all
right this is where we are can you
identify who that is
and muted anybody unmuted except Melissa
and
yourself that's odd okay I'll keep going
um so
this one has similar impacts that the
previous analysis did except the bottom
line if you can see instead of being
137.5 million or excuse me 137.5 million
it's
92.3 million because you're stopping at
that 100% versus the
50% so those are the options we went
over yesterday and then we came up with
this other option based on some feedback
from from the committee yesterday um we
had to make it a little bit bigger and
go out further years to make the impacts
not so great so this impact we cap it we
start it at being capped at 500% so I
know that sounds a lot but taxpayers do
have have those funds on file so we cap
it at 500% of the tax liability in 2022
and then again we phase it in to
250 in 2025 so we skip two years and
then we do another two-year delay which
is what the committee talked about
yesterday and we cap it at 100% in
2027 so again this one the final impact
is the same as the last analysis at 92.3
million however you can see that the
approach is maybe a little bit more
palatable um as the highest impact
wouldn't occur until 2029 at the high
end would be
34.8 or 34.9
million happy to answer any questions on
this uh represent
Janan yes thank you Mr chairman
um the I guess my question is just in
looking at this chart um why is it that
2025 is so much lower than the rest of
the
range it's 5.5 million but above it is
17 million below it's 15.8
million sure so so the way that this
this is phased in um for some of these
numbers and again we take two separate
approaches whether it's the estimates or
whether it's the returns when you're
hitting 2025 you're starting at that
250 for tax year 2025 so it's similar to
the
2022 so if you see in 2022 the high is
4.9 million the 2025 is the same it's
the start of a new tax year so you're
seeing just a little bit of those
estimates being affective in 2025 I see
okay does that make
sense represent southw uh thank you um
thank you for taking my
question do you see any downside to
ending it at 100% based on the uh
returns you're looking
at I I don't know if Dr has a downside I
would say it depends on what your final
goal is obviously reducing it to 100%
doesn't bring the CCO outstanding
liability number down as much as it does
with 50% so
50% uh you're cutting
137 point or 137.5 million out but with
this you're only reducing those
outstanding CCO liabilities by 92.3
million that does seem like that's a big
step to do the
that that at least gets the process
going
and and once you better understand this
and you can make
adjustments representative
Bry uh yeah I was going to say something
similar these are many years so the
legislature can adjust these As Time
Marches on uh and then obviously in 2030
when this this round is done there could
be another bill that would continue the
reductions uh because right now we're at
271 right is that correct 271 million is
the number I think it's 279
279 yeah oh 279 I'm sorry
279 uh with this option we're only going
to get it down by
92 uh who knows what's going to happen
with the taxpayers they may on their own
start reducing this uh without without
nudging from us
so um I I I kind of I'm I'm on the I'll
talk later let me talk later once once
Melissa's done and uh you can put me
after
Ames representative uh
Aly thank you Mr chairman uh Melissa do
we do you have an idea of whether doing
this or even doing the other one would
change the 60 million that you and and
the com controller together have
calculated would if the Auditors got
their way be booked as uh as a liability
in the Surplus statements in the
caffer that's a great question
representative Aly um I haven't looked
at them hand inand
my initial Instinct would be if you're
dealing with a small smaller pool of
people so once this is done white right
we've reduced it down essentially 93.
million so then that scenario I think
would look different however I'm not
sure
how the com troller and KPMG and um the
LBA would look at it at that point would
they look at the outstanding liability
or would they use the same methodology
because I think if we use the same
methodology it would reduce that that 60
million even
further representative
Ames
sorry
um I I guess my first question is
what to make sure I understand this when
you say estimate cumulative fiscal
impact
in the chart I'm looking at which is the
most phased out fa long-term one um
you've got $19 million as the high
number for
2023 I I guess that's cumulative um is
that uh a revenue
loss
yes it
is so um if
if
this committee were to recommend an
amendment to House Bill
two moving away from the
50% proposal to this
one the
[Music]
um the house bill
two um would that that that language
would carry with it the necessity of
reducing um the um Revenue that the
house bill to depends on by $19 million
and that's less than the current
language that's in there which is quite
a lot more is that it do I have that
right you do
okay um and and I don't know whether um
chair chairman
major um I should go go deeper into that
commission idea that I threw out
um why don't we do that when we finish
discussing these
charts okay one thing on the latest
scenario the 500 to
100% is the biggest yearly
impact for over the next four years is
20124 is $17
million in
1526 and 19 and then
it by that time I would imagine that
with the
experience they may make an adjustment
so that it wouldn't get up to 28 and 34
million year
impact the the U cumulative impact
however um
eventually would be
92.3 million dollar as a net loss of
Revenue
y representa
Aly thank you as I understand this on
the the maximum in each case is the
maximum that they think it might be in a
given year but if we look at the
cumulative impact the maximum they think
it might be in this
bium bu the next budget would be 20 um
would be
25 25 24
million
um and the minimum would be
800,000 but I was thinking of taking
maybe 15 million for that the next the
20 24 if we if the whole maximum came in
there would be less money I mean was had
to be sent back on the next uh year 24
there'd be a lot less money to pass send
over because they wouldn't have started
the
250 um tax liability
yet that's the way I'm reading this
unless they can anticipate it which they
may be able to do
um but by
2425 um we'll have at least some idea of
what happened in
2223 and be able to adapt again
especially if there's a commission thank
you further discussion on these
charts
questions I guess I'm back back again
repres Ames yeah so I I do want to say
that um
that
um I've learned a lot I think we've all
learned a lot about credit carryovers in
the last couple of days um and we
received um a lot of information from
the com troller I believe it was com
troller who sent us the audit reports
and the
discussion um between the auditor and
the Dr and Das and um maybe a few other
entities in fact there was a
presentation I was interested to see
that had happened to the to the Senate
Ways and Means Committee um but uh not
to us um so that's by the by um it's a
complicated matter um we're talking
about a a big change here we're talking
about an impact on the budget that's now
under
consideration um there's nothing in what
I've read that suggests to me that this
is an emergency the Auditors have raised
a question the uh agencies have
responded appropriately discussing the
question trying trying to understand it
better sorting out uh what is churn um
just the the natural ins and outs of of
Revenue um and what might be of Greater
concern um sort of a a
growing uh amount of uh of uh liability
that could crash on us um so um that I'm
seeing a a reasoned uh consideration of
a complicated issue and it seems to me
the that we've had little time
to uh understand that fully I'm sure
that I don't fully understand it in
these two or three days that we've been
looking at it um and um that it
deserves a close look I would expect the
Auditors um independent uh rating
agencies if that's an issue here um
would be very respectful of a process
that took as the next step the
establishment of a highlevel commission
to um
address uh this issue in a way that
would be defined in that legislation in
short order um reporting back and making
recommendations for whatever legislation
may be needed next uh fall it could be
that quick I don't see why not I I say
Commission because probably the best way
to do this would be to include the U com
controller and the
treasurer um and Dr um or designes I
don't know sort that out and uh who from
the legislature would sort that out but
um but they would dive into this they
would hold public hearings businesses
that are going to be affected by this
would have a chance to speak to it uh
how do how do they feel about making
this change and uh how do they see the
risks and consequences I'd like to sort
of put this out and um have it
fully considered through a public review
process before we jump into something
that we poorly understand so that's my
thinking thank you representative Ames
uh representative
abon thank you Mr chair um I have
similar
comments uh what did we learned
yesterday uh we learned that these
indeed are revenues that we're talking
about that will impact the budget we
weren't clear on that before
yesterday uh we recognized that that we
had learned that that
KPMG uh the
Auditors um recognize this as an issue
but because of this our controllers
ability to argue that that the liability
would really be no more than 60 million
in a year or by anym I'm not sure uh
that they deemed they KPMG deemed the
risk
immaterial although made note of it in
their audit
report
uh uh we're still not clear uh we we
talked to the Dr about Dr about this
yesterday as to whether how other states
handle this and as of
yesterday we still don't know how other
states handle
this um and the other point is that the
increase in this uh carry forward seems
to be plateauing at around the 279 Mark
I think the last increase was was not
that
great I conclude we need to fix the
problem that the representative
major representative Aly have talked
about for many years uh this brings it
to a head uh now if I had to pick a
solution I would pick this the last
solution because it minimizes the impact
on in in the coming
years but
yesterday I did propose that perhaps we
put a Slowdown on this and why do we
even need this in in house bill to uh
similar to what representative Ames is
saying uh and that we should my
recommendation was that we we just have
a a study
of way house Ways and Means uh give us
more time to prepare a bill for next
year but I certainly am not
opposed to so I don't
think I agree with representative Ames
there's no rush here we've been living
with this issue for a long time and uh I
think once the the the Auditors see that
we have a plan some kind of a plan that
they that that would help uh the
controller out uh with the with the
audits in this in this regard so I I
would uh and I like the idea of a of a
commission with certain players at at
the table uh Beyond uh the house and and
uh and Senate members so I I I would I
would kind of uh agree with
representative Ames I would I would
support his his uh his idea thank you
representative
Aly thank you Mr chairman
um we I think the reason that we ought
to put something into the budget is that
on especially with the commission tied
to it so it can be modified afterwards
but on that we do not know what the risk
really is to the state for this to start
with that's the first thing uh last
night I got from the Dr uh they managed
to find Credit carry forward information
for 2000 FY
2009 uh through
13 on which showed that there was
really very the only slowdown in the
increase of the credit carry forward
amount that we had have was actually in
13 they had no idea why I have no idea
why and uh both of us are uncertain
about whether that information would be
considered accurate today because in
those days we didn't have computers
working uh very well on and they didn't
have budget numbers working very well uh
the place was not very
computerized um but on would but that
would if we went through the greatest
recession in 20
years since 20 years before with no
reduction during the recession in the
credit carry forward that was built up
on we really have no idea why people are
leaving this money in here and that
still makes me incredibly nervous about
when they might take it out on
especially these guys with
500%
250% of of a Year's of their tax
liability for one year um so it is
extremely difficult to get Finance
committees to agree to put something
like this in and
take
uh take uh some reductions in Revenue in
order to be able to to uh lower risk in
future years because they're focused on
the best that they can possibly do for
the two-year period at the point when
the budget is being done and if it can
be put in this year at a rate that is
not going to impact more than I would
say 15 million and I'm sorry I shouldn't
have added the five into the 19 uh it's
19 million possible maximum that could
come out by the end of
uh and but put in 15 million for that
and put in a commission to look at
what's happening in a much deeper way so
that it can then modify what is done now
rather than have to convince them yet
again to face this
issue and I think that it's it's worth
having something in there myself thank
you let me say something
here I've watched
this probably longer than anybody else
has except representing ony and I
constantly ask the
V
why and what are we doing about
it as and over the years nothing's been
done it keeps growing now it's growing
to over a quarter of a billion
dollars and what we're at risk here is
that all of a
sudden for some unknown reason somebody
they might want to take out a 100 milon
$100 million we already plan to spend so
much because we do our budgeting on cash
so that's that's a dangerous liability
that's that's out
there I I like representative Ames
suggestion that we form a
commission study it and that I also like
representative aly's suggestion that we
shouldn't keep pushing this down the
road uh we should start addressing
it and this last scenario that the Dr
came up with shows that if we start the
process the first year in
2022 the biggest impact is $5
million in
2023 largest impact is $14
million and cumulative up to up to 20
but it probably probably wouldn't be
that but at least the process started
and we have a commission the commission
by the end of
should understand it enough to be able
to put a system in place that'll correct
it for the people that have their money
us it also protect the state so what I'd
like to see is a combination of
both is something similar to this last
scenario along with a
commission and I hope that's this is
what comes out of
this represent
Union thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to say that I agree with the
comments you just made um I think
kicking the can down the road on this
would not be a good idea we can still do
both these things we can have a
commission and we can start the process
because if the trend continues and the
trend has been larger and larger if we
wait another year that number May well
be even larger so I think to start the
process totally makes sense um when the
commission comes back with its
conclusions um next year we can easily
we well maybe not easily but we can
alter this path but I agree I like this
last solution the best and I think we do
need to start
on represent spillsbury
[Music]
you need to unmute representative
spillsbury
thank you uh with with the shared screen
I can't see a lot um I'm
sorry my quick question is am I correct
in understanding that if this does not
go into hb2 this year it would be a
two-year lag till the next legislature
before it could be addressed again if it
if it doesn't go into this
year uh no because it's not a it's not a
bill that has been ited if a bill that's
been itl the first year cannot appear
the second year but if we go in with
just a commission the commission uh
would work at this and by the time that
they develop the
solution
uh they might be able to have a bill
next year they might be the following
year so I'm I'm confused about something
because it affects Revenue I thought it
could only be dealt with in a budget
year not to my
knowledge okay hey Mr
chairman yeah
represent thank you I think the problem
is on once the budget is in place if
there's no extra money lying around at
the time we came back with something
that would cost money in a substantial
way which this does uh that the it would
go to the finance committee and they'd
kill
it that's essentially my point uh so
just
to go quickly my I I think we should do
something and initiate something I'm
perfectly comfortable with phasing it in
one of these formats and I'm perfectly
comfortable with having a study
commission that can then revise the
thinking but let's at least kick it
off uh representative
Brony yes thank you Mr chair U I think
I'll ask representative Amy you thinking
of this last
scenario uh that that that could always
be adjusted down the road after the
commission Works uh so that the Maximum
Impact would be 20 and 225 million and
call it 14 million and
23 I could support that plus the
commission representative Murphy hey
Murphy you're back to
us you have to unmute yourself repr
Mercy I just wanted to I'm sorry I was
down I just did uh can you hear me now
I'm in my car we can hear
you
sorry I I I just apologize for being
away we had an explosion outside the
window so but I'm
back okay well thank welcome
aboard thank
you uh representative
Ames thank
you making sure I'm unmuted yeah um so
thank you and I I think uh what's been
suggested this uh combination of uh
doing something concrete and setting up
the commission makes sense um and
um we'd have to work on the phrasing
this would be
this would be a recommendation to the
finance committee for an amendment to
hp2 as I understand it right they've
asked us to look at it and then uh
provide an amendment if we felt
necessary so we'll have to work that out
but uh I think the timing
uh um fits pretty well if we can get
this commission commission going right
away which we if it does become a part
of hp2 then uh it will get going you
know it will be enacted in a timely
fashion and we can get going on it and U
then if it can get its work done in time
for input into the next
budget um then if there need to be
adjustments in this
um in this uh proposal that's in front
of us um those can easily be made in the
context of of a budget um so it all fits
together pretty well and u i favor it
good um further comments representative
Tucker yeah I'm I'm a little surprised
that the advice that we from an auditor
isn't being
taken um that there there must be a way
to that one would go about this that an
auditor would know if nothing else I'm
surprised that the Bond
Council uh who represents the state when
it is bonding money doesn't have an
opinion but I think those are sort of
the two
mainstream ways of coming up with a
solution yeah well the the Auditors if
you read their reports are are
concerned uh but for some reason and
they have been concerned over time but
for some
reason legis
hasn't
reacted well it really shouldn't have to
I mean this is something where the
auditor pretty
well should have the Reigns and
certainly Bond counsel my dealings with
Bond counsel is that they're they're
they're very firm about this sort of
thing and any undue risk at all is
something to be avoided so uh I can't
believe that we need to
be concerned with coming up with
a reasonable
solution okay representa AMS followed by
representative I'm sorry I I had meant
to take my hand down representative
bromy followed by representative Elmer
so for we're gonna move forward with
this we got to decide if representative
bromy yes thank you Mr chair uh if we're
going to move forward with this we've
got to decide if we want the commission
to be done with its work November one of
of
2021 or November one of of
20122 that's the usual dates for the
ends of of commissions November 1st of a
year um and the other thing is that we I
think today we have to come up with are
we GNA select this last version because
we need to come up with uh estimates for
fiscal of the impact for 20 2 and
23 uh if it's this one then it's the
it's up to we'd have to we should as a
group estimate we want to pick the
midpoint of the zero to five million and
the midpoint of 800,000 to 14
million I think those are the two issues
that we got to deal with right now uh
and agree on well three things first do
we want to
accept the 500% 20 250%
version and then ifs then what what kind
of Revenue impact do we want to um give
to to fiscal and then we have to just
pick our a dates that and then also the
structure of the commission uh I don't
know if we need to do that as a group or
not I think someone can maybe a couple
of us can get together and and and come
up with what that structure
is we're getting there representative
Bry representative spilburg
yes thank you Mr chairman um I like the
fourth stage phase down uh
27550 over four consecutive years
that'ss too aggressive uh I'm just
looking at the last chart and wondering
why did Dr prepare it with such
significant time lags rather than in
consecutive years as is the case with
the prior uh Alternatives so this really
stages it
out all the way to
2030 with adjustments in 22 25 and 27
what's the thinking was it just to
stretch it out as far as
possible I would imagine so but to at
least get the uh the process started so
it doesn't hurt that much to begin with
but as far as the other question
is at the end of
24 why settled down to a small amount so
Melissa maybe you could answer
that sure thanks for your question um I
think we did this yeser uh did this
yesterday based on some feedback that we
got from the committee I think one of
the options someone put forth and I'm
sorry I don't remember who did was just
to have a phase in every two years um so
we did we ran like I say we ran multiple
scenarios yesterday and they didn't have
much of a difference from some of the
other ones that we did so we didn't
present them because the the the
differences weren't enough to matter um
but then when we ran this one this one
had more of a difference because we're
starting at that higher 500% and then to
the 250 with the two-year lag um we did
200% to 100% with a 2-year lag and again
it wasn't much of a difference and again
again for
2025 I think representative major you
were just asking the four to five
million at that
point that again is because you're
starting a new tax year at that point
because of the two-year lag so if you
look up top in the title in tax year
2025 we reduce it to
250% and at that point you're feeling a
little bit of the leftover from
2022 but the bulk of it is just the
estimates that that quarter of the
estimates for for um tax year 2025 and
then as you continue you then get
returns for
2025 um in
there representa
Aly thank you Mr chairman I wanted to
answer representative spilsbury's
question the main reason for this and I
think I may have been the one that
suggested maybe going two years in
between on the the main reason for doing
that is to make this tolerable to the
state budget we have an extremely
closely
budgeted uh culture in this state and we
very rarely have any room for
Investments that we would make that
would make things more effective or less
risky and in this case it's kind of like
why isn't the pension system fully
funded right now we wouldn't be able to
do anything else if we did that and we
found out that it was way
underfunded uh in
2007 and are still dealing with that
slowly over a long period of time and
this is is meant to reduce the risk but
if we reduce this risk uh abruptly we
end up without substance abuse treatment
we end up without prisons we end up
without a lot of basic necessities of of
the government and the economy thank
you okay I don't see any hands up so
I've got a
question um the options
are just to do
a
commission or just to do a phase in of
one of these options
that Wella just went through or do a
combination is there anybody here that
wants to do just the
commission guess I'm gonna do
that without doing any phases phasing in
so for just a commission
you have represented Malloy
Phillips Ames and
Jenny now and
burin oh and burn okay sorry about
that next question
is just by phas
in
who who wants to do a just a phase in
put your hand up
uh nobody so the other option is to do a
phas and a commission who would support
that so it looks like the
majority now just to clarify I I didn't
vote for that last one but that's not
because I'm against it as I said I my
preference would be just the commission
so it was a matter of
preference
um so since it's going to be a
combination of both the commission and a
phase
in why don't we start with the last one
first who would be in favor of the one
that gives the longest phas in
the the smallest amount
of uh disruption in the front years and
that allows the commission time to do
the
work this looks like the vast majority
do
that next question
is should we come up with a different
phase in or are we okay with a phase in
that Melissa described in page three
with the 500 capping at
500% in tax year 22
250% at tax year 25 and 100% tax year 27
who would be in favor of that M Mr
chairman this is representative Nunes
you asked two questions there uh you
said is do we need a new one or do we
want this one can we do one question at
a time yeah sorry about that that's okay
I just I'm I'm the confused person here
no no no I I I screwed up
um who wants to generate a new phase in
schedule doesn't look like that many who
likes the phase in shown on page three
which has the 5% 500% 200% and 100% phas
in
it looks like the vast majority so then
are we ready to take a vote uh we need a
motion and representative brahney do you
want to make a motion sure uh I move
that we adopt uh the CC's kept at 500%
of the tax liability ility in in uh
years
22 uh 250% of the tax liability of what
is the T by the way what's the T tax
year oh tax year thank you two
2025 and 100% of the tax liability in in
tax year uh
2027 in
addition we will also uh form a a
commission
uh that would include the Senate and the
house as well as outside experts uh to
continue to evaluate this
issue
second okay the mo that motion's been
made by represent
[Music]
brahney to do the phase
in with the 500%
250% and 100% And to form a commission
uh any further
discussion
representan thank you Mr chairman um my
question would be if we establish a
commission should we have an end date
for that Commission because um it might
be wrong but I'm trying to think the
second year of a bium don't we have to
have new bills in by is it is it
September or November so I just want to
make sure that the commission ends at
the right time yeah and a commission
uh
sometimes doesn't need to honor that
date I've ched many
commissions uh yeah November 1 is a
magical date uh on the second year the
election year uh the commission has to
be done by its work before the election
we are still State reps at that point if
you're on a commission so uh what
happens then there is still time after
the election because new bills can be
filed for the new members as well as old
members so yes there is time to file a
bill on the second year which would be
23 uh uh and and make it into to that
that next uh legislature's business
yeah assumption that the
commission house build once house build
to passes that
section uh is effective 30 days after
passage so get the commission started as
soon as possible yeah may I may I
comment on that yes representative
Ames I favor um a commission that would
be tasked with getting its work
done uh by November of this year
November one if that's the right date uh
rather than put it have it uh continue
for another year um just because I
think there'll be continuity that way
the membership of the legislature
doesn't change and um I think the work
that we're talking about here can be
done in relatively short order um with
an intense effort so I I would favor
that to give you a feel of when the
commission would start
usually the budgets doesn't finally pass
and get signed until towards the end of
June or maybe even to
July and then the commission at that
time would have to start within 30 days
of that so they would have August
through no November to get their work
done so that's sufficient and it should
be sufficient I just uh my personal
experience I chaired the um gambling
commission oversight
commission uh maybe eight or nine years
ago and that came out of the budget just
as this one would and got right to work
uh starting in Late July and did a heck
of a lot of work um and got a report
done by the beginning of
November um that was a pretty
complicated undertaking I think this is
much less so so I think it's totally
manageable yeah and likewise I I chair
that Wayfair commission which is
sh I think that was from July to to
November or
so
um so any further discussion yes
representative
Tucker
represent Tucker you had your hand up
did you want to
talk you muted representative
tuer uh it I took my hand down some time
ago I I'm sorry okay uh representor
bronley yeah um this is what happens so
I agree let's make it to uh November 1st
22 uh when I when when I was involved
with the market-based sourcing un Andi
Norm uh and uh a
commission after that first year we
decided we need more time so we filed a
bill to give ourselves another year so
this could happen in this one if we run
into problems we can always extend it so
I I'll I'm going to amend my my motion
to say that the commission should
complete its work by November 1st
Mr
chairman I think that that's the twoyear
mark 21 thank you add thank
you thank you
suan thank you and I'd like to suggest
that we list the number of PE the people
who would be on the commission now since
it's going to have to be put in what
goes to the finance
committee yeah we can do it now or
uh yeah let's do it
now that would be a representative of
the Dr a representative of the
controller or the controller herself and
the
treasurer and I would like to see
some some high level uh accountant
involved in that thing who might be
willing and able to tell us or tell a
commission why they're leaving the money
there which it would really help to know
okay hold up represent Aly uh
representative
Bernstein you're clerk would you take
down the type of positions we want to
put in this Commission sure so far we
have one from the Dr one from the
controller one from the treasurer and
then a high level
accountant is that correct
representative Aly yes thank you Norm I
think I just we gotta I think the way
the language usually read is the
controller or
designate the treasurer or design each
each one of them with
the right or the commissioner of Revenue
Administration or or design
and then who who do we want to appoint
the accountant do we want the governor
to do that the speaker to do
that the speaker would appoint the the
representatives and
the to be on there and the Senate
President would appoint the Senators the
governor would appoint the
um
C yes but if you had a suggestion you
could give it to the governor because
otherwise it might take a
while
yeah um now who
else should make up the commission it
should be somebody that understands
taxes understands accounting and
understands the
accounting
well you're asking for an accountant do
we have any on ways and means that would
help a lot on either side house or
Senate we could get representative love
joy
back yeah that would be useful
truthfully that would be
useful but
um if we could get somebody from a a
high powerered
accounting firm well we just asked the
uh they come up here and testify
everyone call the New Hampshire
Association of accountants whatever
they're
called representative Smith do you have
any
recommendations I'm thinking about that
I'm not comfortable with the language
High powerered accounting firm because
um I'm not sure that that necessarily um
is the sole determin of Merit um but
um I don't have a particular person I'm
wondering if we should ask
um either ask the um
LBA um about that
um or ask the controller the Dr you know
Dr those people uh the treasurer about a
suggestion good good
suggestion and we
could
have slots maybe three other
positions with recommendations coming
from
the the Dr and the lb
a and whatever I'm not
sure we're not going to solve it right
now let's do the simple one how many
senators how many how many uh
Representatives
yeah I would imagine that you want to
have finance and ways and means
covered uh in both the house and the
Senate so maybe three from the house two
from the
Senate and the Senate will cut it down
to one I know if they cut it down a one
we put it to four make it four and two
if we're gonna invite if we're could
also invite some Finance
members is extremely
important why don't we say four and two
they you're right probably only one
Senator will actually be assigned but um
I would say four and
two I I think the stress should be on
the ways and means uh committee not
evenly between Ways and Means and
finance because of the nature of the the
question so if you had one Finance
person and then either two or three ways
and means I think you'd have the right
the right balance says I as the former
chair of the finance committee um but I
think the
question is a question that clearly
Falls within um The Silo of the Ways and
Means
Committee shouldn't that includes
someone from Ways and Means from both
the Senate and the house that's up to
them thank you oh good point there two
committees over clap each other a lot
for the uh new members remember that the
Senate doesn't do
anything now representative
oler you're not supposed to share that
information okay could I suggest the uh
accountant that was is from Portsmouth
and I can't remember his name but was
head of the business tax commission that
was done five six years ago
yeah okay we have a framework we're not
going to solve everything right now and
the names aren't going to go into the
into the uh the legislation so you have
time to come up with a specific name
right we need to take a vote also have
time
to for the definition and and the goals
and all that not an awful lot of time
but I think we need to just vote on the
concept right
now and make sure that Mr Shay is clear
on what you want to go into the
uh the language for House Bill too then
what Chris will do he will generate
something get it back to us so we can
look it
over that quickly to see if if it's what
we want make our comments and update and
then uh we can finish
it is this today or
tomorrow I've got to take this one Pat
we take
over a question Susan I'm sorry on well
he he says that Chris should go away and
generate the language and then we should
look it over and I'm asking whether
we're going to do this this afternoon or
tomorrow
sometime tomorrow is our deadline well
tomorrow is a deadline to get uh our
Revenue estimates to fiscal I think we
we could have a couple extra days to get
them this revised Amendment this this
amendment hb2 I don't think I don't
think F Friday they wanted a number
fiscal one we we will need to vote on a
number for credit carry forward then yes
we still have to do that that's the last
thing we have to do
uh representative spillsbury
I was just going to make the same point
that we need to come up for the figures
on hb2 okay representative burin yeah I
just want to review this commission and
maybe we can get this done before uh
Norm gets back okay so right now uh and
I just pulled from what everyone was
saying we have 10 members to this
commission it would be one from the Dr
one from the Controllers Office one from
the treasurer's office one from the
accounting industry one from the
LBA three from the house two from the
Senate that equals
10 I don't think the LBA feels like it
can join that Chris Chris
is uh uh Chris Chris uh thank you um
representative of bramy and ali um yeah
our office would prefer not to be on
assigned as a member of a commission
however we can work with the commission
you know we can come in and testify
before the commission and provide
comment on um the audit procedures that
have been involved with the uh carry
credit carry forward um but not be
assigned to the commission itself so we
could put a statement in a um a bill
that basically says you know that that
the commission can work with or would
have input from the legislative budget
assistant but um I don't think we would
want to be on a a commission that would
eventually lead to some legislation that
might lead to something we'd have to
audit later
on okay then one other idea I'll float
out there is from the
Bia um perhaps the accounting industry
would be a representative somewhat of
the private sector but maybe we should
hear from Bia as
well well you've got the Bia and then
you've got the small business realators
and the Federation of Independent
Business whatever you got three or four
different uh industry groups
there let's pick one Norm you're back
right you wanna Norm you're muted Norm
Norm you
muted
the the viia is probably the most
extensive
so the B well we're talking about large
businesses so they would be
appropriate yeah yeah the others are
represent the smaller
businesses okay we got it formulated
enough so that we can take a vote and
then
uh we'll work out the details with with
Chris have hands up
Norm uh represent spur Jenny had her
hand up but then she took it down she
wanted yeah go
ahead quick question don't have
experience with these commissions but uh
two points wouldn't it be sensible to
have an odd number and second wouldn't
the way to be dealing with Bia and
Realtors Etc is to have them come before
the commission and provide
testimony you're
right so we were at an odd number before
we added the
Bia well I I think we should I just to
chime in I I agree it should be an odd
number and I also agree that we
shouldn't specify one of the
organizations as the source of a
particular
of a slot um rather it should be the um
if we want somebody uh from the business
sector we say so or whatever we we we
Define
the the kind of experience that we want
the person to bring but not uh the exact
Source yeah okay so currently we have 10
members to this commission we should
either add or delete one so we can come
up with that odd number
had one
representative we had nine before we put
in the Bia I thought we were talking
about not putting it in all right can
can uh can the clerk read the names
again sure here's what I have now and I
uh one from the Dr one from the
controller's office one from the
treasurer's office one from the
accounting industry one from the
business sector two from the house two
from the Senate that equal was
nine well we don't want two from I think
we had more from the house we had three
but in an effort to get it to an odd
number I reduced it by one so I I'll
make it back to three so now we have 10
members I thought that we weren't going
to put an industry member on it we were
just gonna have them
come to delete business sector is
everyone comfortable with
that just the vote how many from the
Senate two from the Senate and in par
parenthetically I have one from Finance
one from Ways and
Means in the house I have three members
one from Finance two from ways and
means our new uh state senator from
Littleton is a
CPA are the
Auditors do the Auditors are they
accountants and they would
yes that would be the accounting
industry would represent the Auditors
the New Hampshire Association of
certified public accountants or some
organization like that okay thank
you all right so we're we're at nine if
everyone's comfortable with
that one more time Dr controller
Treasurer accounting
industry three from the house two from
the Senate equals n
yeah fine if it's true that the Senate
typically only is going to appoint one
we'll be back to an even number
again I'd rather just appoint one
Senator and make it make it three house
members okay that brings us down to
eight no to make add another house
member that would make it four house
members and one Senator right bringing
the total to nine that's fine that's
good okay we beat this
thing let's move on we have a great way
of getting to
yes what else do we have to do
to get a vote on
this are we
okay then we need the technical language
done from Dr I think
yeah we can vote the
concept and then leave it leave it to uh
the Dr to come up with the preliminary
language get it to us we'll get it to
the committee and has to be done right
away for comments and and get it
back and we're on our
way
so who wants to make the
motion I I made the I made the I thought
there's a motion on the floor right now
yes there is a motion was made
byamy with Amy second right all we're
doing is we amended theemotion a motion
to uh do what we just did to add the
commission and the the makeup of the
commission would be added to that motion
and effective within 30 days of passing
and uh completed November 1st 20 21
yes chairman could I
ask
yes if somehow the budget gets delayed
again which has been fairly often in the
last decade uh to the fall the
commission really wouldn't have
time we'll cross that bridge when it
comes to it if the budget gets delayed
we put another amendment in
the fall
right okay are we ready for the question
I think representative has a
question who's
that
representative yes instead of 30 days
why don't it say upon passage that gives
us more time that's all upon
passes so are we
ready um Pat this is your motion do you
agree with that upon pass I was gonna
say yes that's fine I I agreed a minute
to uh upon
passage I
agree all right are we ready for the
vote representative Bernstein would you
take the vote on that Mo sure thank you
Mr chair
so uh this vote will relate to credit
carryovers and we're going to adopt the
phase in model of 500% 250% and 100%
phase in additionally we will establish
a commission to study the issue the
commission will conclude November 1st
2021 it will be comprised of nine
members and this will be effective upon
passage if everyone is clear on the
question we'll begin the roll call Vote
with representative abrami yes
Aaron yes oy yes obber yes
ducet yes CLK votes yes Elliot yes
janigian yes Nunes yes Baxter yes
spillsbury
yes
tutor I didn't hear anything
representative
tutor
give me a thumbs up because I'm not sure
the audio is
working on the screen do we oh there he
is he's there he is there representative
tutor okay we're g to come back to
representative tutor represented Devy
yes Ames yes Southworth yes Malloy yes
representative Thomas shamberg
representative shamberg votes yes Tucker
yes
garlo yes Smith yes Lane yes hackin
Phillips yes
Murphy yes representative
tutor Mr chair what do you
advise can somebody
oh hey Paul can you hear
us Paul do you vote Yes or
No Mr chair I think he's Frozen perhaps
he could put his can he put his hand up
thumbs up if you vote Yes just put your
hands up
Paul you take your video down you could
speak
we know you're
there okay just to to move this on and I
don't think it's a critical vote here so
I'm just going to say he's not voting
then we have repres we have chairman
major please cast your
vote Mr chair the vote is 23 to nothing
in favor vote 23 to nothing in favor and
that is we're in favor of making an
amendment to do the credit carryover
shown on page three of the hand off on
the
Dr which has the liability cap at 500%
250% and 100% in addition to that
forming a commission effective upon
passage re reporting out November
1st and having nine
members
it passes 23 to zero very good thank you
for a great day
people repr nor major we have to vote on
the amount of money we think it's going
to cost the
budget uh
yes just sent out a letter saying it's
going to cost us T
much
okay I would
suggest since up to
four
4938 on 22 in between 802 to
14.1 53 how about if we just use the
middle of the range on representative
major they the Dr was saying that we
should be towards the higher
end on
the and if we I
don't I think 15 million for both is a
fairly on good guess at this point
and if we split it so it was 4 million
the first year and and 11 million the
second year that would get us to 15
million but if someone else has got
another
idea um does that seem reasonable for
the
committee okay with that representative
major okay you make that a motion
representative
Aly yes uh I'll make a motion that the
credit carry forward uh amendment that
we are proposing to the finance
committee on would
cost um 4 million in
fy22 and 11 million in FY 23 I second
that I wonder representative major um if
uh what essentially what we're doing is
we're proposing an
amendment to an existing
provision that has an even greater
negative
impact yes so I'm wondering if the
um
if it should the representation of what
this amendment does is that reducing the
negative impact the financial impact of
the existing
provision section such and such of the
hb2 from and then we'd have to have a
number or from a rounded and estimated
number to these numbers that have just
been mentioned I think that context is
rather important in terms
of that would
be
Chris
yes with these two numbers you
could get an
amendment that accomplishes this
right so I can I can get an amendment
that um sets up the commission that
you're talking about and changes which
um in House Bill two as it relates to
the the carry credit to meet what you've
just voted on and I'd work with Dr to
get that language um in terms of the
value you just want to make a statement
um to the finance committee as to the
cost of your Amendment right and I think
what rep am is asking or suggesting is
that you should let let the finance team
that you're going to be talking to know
that instead of an impact of say $40
million it's now going to be only $15
million
exactly so we wouldn't have to divide it
by the year you don't necessarily
because you did that with me right now I
mean when represent major and talks with
the represent wer for instance he would
want to say we expect four million in 22
and 11 million in
23 um just to get that statement but I I
know that's the intent of ways and means
and I would convey that to Mike Kane to
include that on the Surplus in that way
oh
okay but in terms of the amendment um we
we would just get an amendment to
replace those sections in house bill to
I would would put it in your name rep of
major to start with um get get it back
to you to distribute to the committee to
make sure they're okay with it um and
then once you guys all are okay we would
um then forward it over to um house
finance and let them know that this is
what wayin means is recommending replace
sections uh 102 through
okay I think the motion that we're we're
talking about here now is really to add
change the numbers on line 10 of the
change in revenues due to legislative
changes
report we're changing the
numbers from the 15 million down to 4
million and the 39.8 million down to the
million
that that's what we're voting right
that's
perfect any other questions on that uh
representative YY you have your hand yes
thank you um um Mr
chair the question is if I'm trying to
remember in the past have we included
the CC or Co your credit carry over have
we included that as on the revenue side
or if we ignore it in the past and if
we've ignored it in the past then
there's no fiscal impact but if we've
included it as Revenue than there is I'm
could you refresh my memory on that
that's the problem that's been put in as
Revenue oh well hell then we have to
tell it yeah all right thank
you I forgot that thank
you there's a lot of money out
there liability um so are we
clear representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman um I get that
we're proposing to change to minus four
andus
11 don't we have an obligation to report
to the finance committee the fiscal
impact of
hb2 as it's written and therefore aren't
we going to have to provide
the5 and thega 39.8 as well and show
them two
scenarios I will give them a copy of of
what Melissa what the Dr gave us which
shows
that so they're going to see the 15 and
the 39.8 figures as
well what they're going to see is on
chck on page
three what this scenario does in
2022 it could be anywhere from 0 to 49
million
where we're estimating it's going to be
minus four and the second year they're
going to see
82,000 to 14 million and we're going to
tell we estimate it is
11 Mr
chairman yes I think that they also need
to see uh the bottom of page one which
is the the possible cost of each year
under what is now in
hb2 we're going to get the
works
good representative Smith has her hand
up I'll go over with them I'll have
Melissa with
me anything else before we vote on it
representative Smith has her hand up nor
representative
Smith thank you Mr chair I just want to
point out that I think this is why we
pay the LBA all those big bucks that
their obligation is to
explain um in the probably in the
Surplus statement but maybe elsewhere
about the difference between what is in
fact in house bill one and two now and
how this will make make changes um and
because it has to go in a number of
different places both in the language in
house buil to and then in the in the
revenue
estimates thank you representative
Smith no I have one more thing um
because we're voting for what's going to
appear in this change in revenues due to
legisa of changes
report the title the item is stated as
now as business profits tax credit carry
forward limited to 50% of total tax
liability we may want to we can still
use that but but as amended we may have
to put as amended in there for the new
numbers yes good
catch Patrick where where's the
reference in the in the report that that
we went over earlier today the change in
revenues due to legislative changes
report yeah that we talked through then
we we we vote on but that one line uh
business pro okay okay got it all I'm
suggesting is we say as amended if we
put the new numbers in the minus four
and
minus1 and LBA will have their own
format when they put this yeah yeah I
think we we've got it licked I
think so are we ready to vote on
line 10 which is the business profits
tax Car Credit carry
forward we changed it to minus four
for fy22 and minus 11 million for FY
23 and then where it says limited to 50%
total liability as
[Music]
amended okay then uh representative
Burns you take the
vote thank you Mr chair let's begin the
roll call Vote with representative
abrami yes Aaron yes
oy
obber representative obber did I not say
yes yes perhaps he did and I didn't hear
representative duet yes the clerk votes
yes Elliot yes janigian yes nunz yes
Baxter yes
spilsbury yes tutor yes twice okay thank
you Aly yes Ames yes Southworth yes
Maloy yes representative Thomas shamberg
representative shamberg votes yes Tucker
yes goar
Carlo yes Smith yes Lane yes hacken
Phillips yes
Murphy yes chairman major yes Mr chair
the motion carries by a vote of 24 to
nothing the mo the vote been 24 to
nothing the motion
to change the numbers relative to the
credit Carri forward to to minus $4
million for fy22 and minus 11 for FY 23
and also add as amended to the
title thank
you now is there any other business we
need to do
today can you can you just uh go what
we're gonna do on Tuesday with the house
bills that we have
left right on what we're going to do is
I scheduled all three days next
week uh in the schedule such as revenue
and house bills and and house bills
we're going to have a work session and
executive session on the remaining house
bills that we heard we're not going to
deal with the Senate
bills and
uh I'm hoping that we might be able to
get somebody talk the stimulus package
coming in we need to that understanding
that stimulus package that would be
great all
right then thank you comish an awful lot
today and I thank rep representative
Smith representative Lane
and
AR so are we meeting
tomorrow no no
okay you can have a meeting if you want
however the Democrats will have a caucus
Saturday
again okay thank you I gotta go meet my
wife thank you thank you thank
you